Hey, Sean, hey, what's up? Hey, it's me. I know, it's you just said your name. I know I'm just talking to you. Just relax about it. Hey, we're about to do another episode of SmartLess. Hey, for Tracy, cold open. This is a cold open.
嘿，肖恩，嘿，怎么了？嘿，是我。我知道，你刚才说了你的名字。我知道，我只是在跟你说话。放轻松点。嘿，我们马上要录制另一期《SmartLess》了。嘿，特蕾西，冷开场。这是一个冷开场。
Cold Open is like, hey, she knows what cold open is. Hey, shut up. I'm talking to her right now. Just give me two seconds. I've got to explain what a cold open is. She knows what a cold open. It's said it a million times. Oh, Tracy, cold opens what you say at the beginning of an episode before you start the episodes
冷开场就是，嘿，她知道什么是冷开场。嘿，闭嘴。我现在正在跟她说话。给我两秒钟。我得解释一下什么是冷开场。她知道什么是冷开场。已经说过一百万次了。哦，特蕾西，冷开场就是你在节目开始前，在正式开始之前说的话，
so people know you're starting the episode. I'm exhausted. Me too. Me as well. Don't forget about me. Also me. Welcome to SmartLess. Smart. Less.
这样人们就知道你要开始节目了。我精疲力竭了。我也是。我也是。别忘了我。还有我。欢迎来到《SmartLess》。Smart。Less。
Oh, God. That was probably our surprise guest. Our surprise guest fell in it. You probably just... Oh, no. Uh, where are, so let's see, everybody is at home base, it seems like, uh, you know, Willie, where are you? I'm on Long Island. Oh, you're back there. Oh, what are you doing back there?
哦，天哪。那大概是我们的惊喜嘉宾。我们的惊喜嘉宾掉进去了。你可能刚才……哦，不。呃，我们在哪，让我们看看，大家似乎都在大本营，呃，你知道，威利，你在哪？我在长岛。哦，你回到那儿了。哦，你回那儿干什么？
Our little R&R? I just made a little quick scoot out here for, uh, for a night. What, did you like, forget a pair of shoes you really liked out there? No, Jason. No, but I mean, seriously, isn't it a hassle trying to figure out what you're going to keep in your second home's closet versus, um, what's back in Los Angeles? Is it mostly winter wear out there on the island? There's a lot of winter wear.
我们的小小休养生息？我只是为了，呃，为了待一晚，匆匆忙忙赶到这儿。怎么，你是忘了带一双你特别喜欢的鞋子吗？不，杰森。不，但我是说，说真的，要决定在第二个家的衣橱里放什么，而不是，嗯，留在洛杉矶，这不是很麻烦吗？岛上是不是大部分都是冬装？确实有很多冬装。
And it's chilly out here right now, so it's been really, it was beautiful, beautiful, beautiful. No, I came out of here with my little guy yesterday, and just to kind of stick around, we were walking around, went into town, went to the bookstore. Well, that's nice.
而且这儿现在很冷，所以真的很棒，非常非常美。不，我昨天带着我的小家伙出来，只是为了待一会儿，我们四处走走，进了城，去了书店。嗯，那很好。
Yeah, it cranked up the pool, even though it's cold out, it's real fun. Yeah. And just super nice. Does he swim? yet yeah he does you know yes he's he's in the process of learning sink slowly now slower yeah he's he's he's five so he's not but he's come a long way like he's you know he does that thing where like he can swim underwater you know so they whatever they don't can't do in
是啊，把泳池加热了，尽管外面很冷，但真的很有趣。是啊。而且超级棒。他会游泳吗？还没，他会，你知道，是的，他正在学习慢慢下沉，现在更慢了，是的，他五岁了，所以他还没学会，但他进步很大，就像他，你知道，他会做那种事，他可以在水下游泳，你知道，所以他们无论什么，他们做不到的
terms of strokes they just can do it underwater get a hey dad yeah that means he can't swim you know swimming is trying to keep yourself buoyant and above you know I know you know I know. I can't really swim, you know. Did you guys? Is that true? Yeah, I was petrified. Are you, are you a weak swimmer? Yeah, I can.
泳姿，他们只是可以在水下完成，嘿爸爸，是的，那意味着他不会游泳，你知道游泳是试图让自己保持浮力并浮在水面上，你知道，我知道你知道，我知道。我真的不会游泳，你知道。你们呢？那是真的吗？是的，我当时吓坏了。你是，你是个不擅长游泳的人吗？是的，我可以。
I don't know how to do it. I run out of breath in like 10 seconds. No, truly. Yeah, I can. I don't have the, I don't have the lung support to swim. Well, that's not true. Well, you don't know how to do it. You don't know how to do it.
我不知道怎么做。我大概10秒钟就喘不过气来了。不，真的。是的，我可以。我没有，我没有肺活量来游泳。嗯，那不是真的。嗯，你不知道怎么做。你不知道怎么做。
You sing. If you swim, you don't need. How do you not have the lung? You don't need to hold your breath if you can actually swim. Yeah, but the actual aerobic kind of movements that make your heart pump faster than you have to breathe faster. I just fail. really quickly at it.
你唱歌。如果你会游泳，你不需要。你怎么会没有肺活量？如果你真的会游泳，你不需要屏住呼吸。是的，但实际的有氧运动会让你的心脏跳动得更快，然后你必须呼吸得更快。我只是在这一方面很快就失败了。
Okay. Do you know what I mean? Hang on. Yeah, go ahead. Please, do you do this one, Will. I just want to take this one apart a little bit. I can't be the only person. That can't swim?
好吧。你知道我的意思吗？等等。是的，继续。拜托，你来做这个，威尔。我只是想稍微拆解一下这个。我不可能是唯一一个不会游泳的人吧？
No, you're not. But do you... You get too tired to keep yourself from drowning. That's what it is. That's what it is. Well, is that because you're panicking and so you're catching your short of breath? No, I think maybe I just do too much too quickly. I don't realize how to...
不，你不是。但你……你太累了，无法让自己不溺水。就是这样。就是这样。嗯，那是因为你惊慌失措，所以你呼吸短促吗？不，我想也许我做得太多太快了。我不知道怎么……
I don't know how to swim, so I paddle really, fast than I use up all my energy really quickly. He's in an immediate panic. Yeah, I do. I wish people could see the motions that Shoney's doing. Shoney, do you, did you ever take swim lessons? Clearly not. He's moving both hands at the same time, listener.
我不知道怎么游泳，所以我划水划得非常快，然后我很快就耗尽了所有能量。他陷入了即时的恐慌。是的，我确实。我希望人们能看到肖恩正在做的动作。肖恩，你，你曾经上过游泳课吗？显然没有。听众朋友们，他两只手在同时动。
Instead of, you know, most of us rotate, right hand, left hand, right arm, left arm. I only know. But, Sean, you can, you exercise and you don't run out of breath. I know. I don't understand it. So it's not that you don't. What about, like, walking up a bunch of steps? Like, if you walk up.
而不是，你知道，我们大多数人是旋转的，右手，左手，右臂，左臂。我只知道。但是，肖恩，你可以，你锻炼的时候不会喘不过气来。我知道。我不明白。所以不是你不能。那，比如，走上一堆台阶呢？比如，如果你走上。
up too many stairs, you don't just like collapse and roll down the stairs, right? No, no, no, I don't. I don't know what it is about the swimming or the pool. Just go slower up the stairs so that you can make it. Are you swimming, like, have you got a... Like, I don't float. Right, well, none of us too.
走太多台阶，你不会只是崩溃然后滚下楼梯，对吧？不，不，不，我不会。我不知道游泳或泳池是怎么回事。只是走楼梯慢一点，这样你就能走上去。你在游泳吗，比如，你有一个……比如，我不会浮起来。对，好吧，我们都没人会。
That's surprising. Do you, I mean, have you got like a corn dog in your hand? What's going on that you... By the way, I love a corn dog. It should be netted. In the pool. I fucking love a corn dog. I really, I do too.
这很令人惊讶。你，我是说，你手里拿着热狗吗？发生了什么事让你……顺便说一句，我喜欢热狗。它应该被网住。在泳池里。我他妈的爱死热狗了。我真的，我也喜欢。
And I feel like they've kind of gone by the way of like the bungee jumping and things like that. I mean, I wouldn't know if I put them in the same category as bungee jumping. I want to know where all the stretch limousines and the corn dogs have gone. But you get some, you get a corn dog, you get a corn dog and you dip it in some just yellow French's mustard. Yes, that's the best ever. Forget it. I know. What about some of the little cheese, little cheese dip?
我觉得它们有点像蹦极之类的东西一样过时了。我是说，我不知道我是否会把它们归为蹦极那一类。我想知道所有的加长豪华轿车和热狗都去哪了。但你买一些，你买一个热狗，你买一个热狗，然后把它蘸上一些黄色的法式芥末酱。是的，那是史上最好的。算了吧。我知道。那一点点奶酪，一点点奶酪蘸酱呢？
Oh, yeah. Yeah, throw it in a little tub of cheese. Yeah, I'll do that. A hot dog on a stick was a big spot out here with the funny multicolored hats. Hot dog on a stick. Where was that? No, never heard of it. Yeah, we had a bunch of those like in the valley.
哦，是的。是的，把它扔进一小桶奶酪里。是的，我会那样做。热狗棒在这一带是个大热门，戴着滑稽的多色帽子。热狗棒。那是在哪？不，从来没听说过。是的，我们在山谷里有很多那种店。
There was some out at the beach. Sean, I'm surprised you're not a hot dog on a stick guy. I don't. I'm who says I'm not? I try it. I'll try it. No, no, no. But I mean, that was like that was a famous, that was a great spot.
海滩上也有一些。肖恩，我很惊讶你不是个热狗棒爱好者。我不。谁说我不是？我试试。我会试试。不，不，不。但我是说，那是一个著名的，那是一个很棒的地方。
What about it? What about a, I had this discussion with somebody? What about a pig in a blanket? Yeah, I do enjoy those Yeah, putting a puff pastry Anything with a puff pastry Speaking of which, I have not seen Scotty in a long time Yeah, he's just around this guy
那怎么样？那怎么样，我和某人讨论过这个问题？那猪在毯子里（香肠卷）呢？是的，我很喜欢那些。是的，放进酥皮里。任何有酥皮的东西。说到这个，我已经很久没见到斯科蒂了。是的，他就在这家伙身边。
Yeah, he's all tidied up on the couch Oh, sorry, no, that's a bear and a comforter Sorry, I've confused the two Cubs and a comforter Oh my God, it's a cub furter Scottie's gonna kick my ass when he sees me next. That's really funny.
是的，他整整齐齐地躺在沙发上。哦，抱歉，不，那是一只熊和一条被子。抱歉，我把两者搞混了。幼崽和被子。哦，天哪，那是幼崽被子。斯科蒂下次见到我一定会踢我的屁股。那真的很有趣。
Well, listen, that's a great cue for a guest. What if you just panned over? And he's on the couch. Just in like a snuggy. Yeah. What if you just walked up to Scuddy, just sort of squirting French's mustard on? Taking big bites or licks.
好吧，听着，那是嘉宾的一个很好的提示。如果你只是平移过去呢？他就在沙发上。穿着连体睡衣。是的。如果你只是走到斯科蒂身边，只是往他身上挤法式芥末酱呢？大口咬或舔。
Here goes. Here goes. Guys, we got a real live one today. All right? This guest is a man with 10. talent, looks, smarts. He's got many nominations, plenty of wins, box office, sock, critical respect. He's got massive dramatic range, razor sharp comedic skills, and a British accent.
开始了。开始了。伙计们，我们今天有个真正的活宝。好吗？这位嘉宾是一个拥有才华、外貌、智慧的男人。他有很多提名，有很多奖项，票房大卖，备受评论界尊重。他有巨大的戏剧表演范围，极其敏锐的喜剧技巧，还有英国口音。
That's the triple crown. But most importantly, he's got a wife. He's got three sons and one of the best names in the Screen Actors Guild Directory. Friends, say hello to Benedict Cumberbatch. No kidding. Come on, Al. I was going to guess it. He's got two middle names, too.
那是三冠王。但最重要的是，他有个妻子。他有三个儿子，还有演员工会名录里最好的名字之一。朋友们，向本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇问好。别开玩笑了。来吧，阿尔。我本来要猜到的。他还有两个中间名呢。
Two middle names. What are they? What are they? As if it wasn't enough, Benedict Timothy Carlton. Timothy Carlton. It gets better. I use them on off days. No, that's dad's name. It's a thing of just trying to squeeze the whole family into one small child's head.
两个中间名。它们是什么？它们是什么？好像这还不够，本尼迪克特·蒂莫西·卡尔顿。蒂莫西·卡尔顿。这更好了。我在休息日用它们。不，那是爸爸的名字。这只是试图把整个家庭塞进一个小孩脑袋里的事。
Benedict Timothy, what is it again? Carlton. Carlton Cumberbatch. Yeah. Fabulous. How are you? So nice to meet you. Drink him in, you guys.
本尼迪克特·蒂莫西，再说是哪个？卡尔顿。卡尔顿·康伯巴奇。是的。太棒了。你好吗？很高兴见到你。你们这些家伙，好好欣赏他吧。
I'm good. I mean, I'm already. I mean, I'm just. I've got a rictus grin on my face. I can hardly speak not only because of that absurdly nice introduction, but it's a real privilege to listen to the top of the show as your surprise guest. And I was panicking it, oh, Christ. If I laugh, will they hear me laugh?
我很好。我是说，我已经。我是说，我只是。我脸上带着僵硬的笑容。我几乎说不出话来，不仅是因为那个荒谬的好介绍，而且作为你们的惊喜嘉宾来听节目的开头是一种真正的荣幸。我当时很恐慌，哦，天哪。如果我笑，他们会听到我笑吗？
Would you completely moose me at the beginning or not? If Bennett and Rob were on the stick, they'd have your mic down before we introduce you, and instead we're hearing you dropping shit, Bennett, Rob, God damn it. No, there was a sound like my body dropping with shock at being a surprise guest. And that was that I am in my house with my wife, and the full mention three kids. So that was probably the wind catching a door. Let's hope it's not a temper tantrum because I'm not like that.
你们会在开头完全把我搞砸吗？如果贝内特和罗布在控制，他们会在我们介绍你之前就把你的麦克风关掉，而我们却听到你掉东西的声音，贝内特，罗布，该死。不，那声音听起来像是我因为作为惊喜嘉宾而震惊得身体掉落的声音。那大概是风吹动了门。希望不是因为发脾气，因为我不是那样的人。
How old are the boys? Or an intruder. They are. Yeah, guys, I've got to go. She's quite serious. Don't get murdered on the show. No, that'd be great, great ratings. That would be a first.
男孩们多大了？或者是一个入侵者。他们是。是的，伙计们，我得走了。她很严肃。别在节目里被谋杀了。不，那会很棒，收视率会很高。那将是第一次。
Ratings. The boys are how old? Six, eight and ten. Six, eight and ten. Well planned. Yeah. Jesus. Was that on purpose?
收视率。男孩们多大了？六岁、八岁和十岁。六岁、八岁和十岁。计划得很好。是的。天哪。那是故意的吗？
Kind of. Let's do two years apart? Kind of, yes. We did want to get on with it. Yeah. And so he's a trooper. She's amazing. Good thinking.
算是吧。我们每两年要一个？算是吧，是的。我们确实想继续下去。是的。所以他是个勇士。她太棒了。好主意。
I didn't, for some reason, you know, because people know, I'm super bright. I missed it. I wanted three, and I just didn't plan it well. And there's a five-year gap between the two. And then we just aged out. Couldn't have a third, you know? Oh, great story. Hey.
我没有，出于某种原因，你知道，因为人们知道，我超级聪明。我错过了。我想要三个，但我没计划好。两个之间有五年的差距。然后我们就过了生育年龄。没法生第三个，你知道？哦，很棒的故事。嘿。
That's a fall. By the way, or you could do what I did. Just have the gap anyway. And they just, you know. Oh, and just reload. Yeah, sorry, hang on. Is it a better way to say that. Is it a better way to say that.
那是一个跌倒。顺便说一句，或者你可以做我做的事。无论如何都要有差距。然后他们只是，你知道。哦，只是重新装填。是的，抱歉，等等。这是更好的说法吗？这是更好的说法吗？
So to speak. Still rolling. Unload? Let's reset. What? Oh, Jesus. Benedict, is that something, the three kids? Is it something that, is it like, did you guys agree to a number?
可以这么说。还在录。卸载？让我们重置。什么？哦，天哪。本尼迪克特，那是某种东西吗，三个孩子？那是某种，你们同意了一个数字吗？
Or is it just like, well, we're living? living life and this is what happened. Sophie comes from three. No, I'm an only chance. I panicked when our second was on the way. And what do you do? Do you divide yourself? How do you love as much both things
还是说，嗯，我们正在生活？过日子，这就是发生的事情。苏菲来自三个孩子的家庭。不，我是独生子。当我们的第二个孩子在路上时，我惊慌失措。你该怎么办？你把自己分开吗？你怎么能同样爱两件事
without necessarily having more time to do that? And, you know, there are the odd moments when you're on a kind of solo date with one of them and you kind of go, am I really cheating out of a lot of this? But then you see them when they're not trying to kill each other, getting on as friends and think, no, I've given you the gift of a lifetime
而不一定有更多的时间去做呢？而且，你知道，偶尔会有一些时刻，当你和其中一个进行某种单独约会时，你会想，我是不是真的在很多方面亏待了另一个？但当你看到他们没有试图杀死对方，而是像朋友一样相处时，你会想，不，我给了你一生中最珍贵的礼物，
that'll outlast me. have three you have two people in your life that will always be there yeah do you want it or not at times but you know it's it's amazing so i i swung around to the idea pretty quickly and i love it i love it they're like a kind of tribe of cubs running yeah you sort of like you started to go there a bit on like as i thought about that when i had my second kid i was like well wait am i going to be able to love this one as much as i love the first one and you're like are you an only child no i i have a sister just acts like one yeah What do you say?
它会比我活得更久。有三个，你生命中有两个人会永远在那里。是的，你想要它吗？有时，但你知道，这太神奇了，所以我很快就转而接受了这个想法，我爱它，我爱它，他们就像一群幼崽在奔跑。是的，你有点像，当你想到那个时，你开始往那方面想，当我有了第二个孩子时，我就想，好吧，等等，我能像爱第一个那样爱这个吗？你是独生子吗？不，我有一个妹妹，她表现得像个独生子。是的，你说什么？
But no, like, when I had, when we had Maple, we already had Frannie, and five years later we had Maple, and I was so crazy about Frannie, and then here comes Maple, right? A stranger comes in the house, brand new baby, and you're just like,
但不，就像，当我们有了梅普尔，我们已经有了弗兰妮，五年后我们有了梅普尔，我当时对弗兰妮太疯狂了，然后梅普尔来了，对吧？一个陌生人进了屋子，全新的婴儿，你只是想，
well, I can't wait to get to know you. I hope I love you as much as the first one. And like, what, you, it's a tall order. It turns out. Did you do that? I love to. No, but then. She would be talking about it.
嗯，我迫不及待想了解你。我希望我能像爱第一个那样爱你。而且，什么，你，这是一个艰巨的任务。事实证明。你做到了吗？我喜欢。不，但后来。她会谈论它的。
I think a lot of parents probably go through that, right? Whether you're aware of it or not. I think it's a very natural reaction because the first time you have a child that is, I said, oh, your entire, all of it changes to your orbit of the world, the way you see your parents, your place in that whole thing is just utterly realized at a very real moment. And that is it is what I'm trying to say. You think, oh, this is it. This is what life's about.
我想很多父母可能都会经历那个，对吧？无论你是否意识到。我认为这是一种非常自然的反应，因为你第一次有孩子时，我说，哦，你的整个，所有的一切都改变了你的世界轨道，你看待父母的方式，你在那整个事情中的位置在非常真实的时刻完全实现了。这就是我想说的。你以为，哦，就是这样。这就是生活的意义。
And you go, oh, no, but it's until the next one, it has to be the same. And it is. But it's weird. It's the same as women forgetting most of the time, but, you know, that physiologically forget, apparently, the birth pain about what women go through. Yeah, I can't imagine. Otherwise, why would your human body even want to be able to be impregnated?
然后你说，哦，不，但直到下一个，它必须是一样的。确实如此。但这很奇怪。这和女性大部分时间忘记一样，但是，你知道，生理上忘记，显然，女性所经历的分娩痛苦。是的，我无法想象。否则，为什么你的身体甚至想要能够怀孕？
You know, it's just the whole thing. Or wear heels. It focuses on this, it heals. Sure. We're just, you know. Go ahead, Will. No, I'm not expanding on that. You don't want to touch that one?
你知道，这整件事。或者穿高跟鞋。它专注于这个，它愈合。当然。我们只是，你知道。继续，威尔。不，我不会对此进行扩展。你不想碰那个？
No, I don't want to touch any of it. But it is fun. And what's amazing, too, is how different, and God, I'm like the quadrillionth person to bring this up, but I also have three boys, Benedict, and how entirely different they are from each other. Absolutely. Even my boys who are less than two years apart are so vastly different personality-wise. And had virtually the same experience growing up, you know. And I've said this before.
不，我不想碰任何那部分。但这很有趣。而且令人惊奇的是，不同之处，天哪，我是第几亿个提出这一点的人，但我也有三个男孩，本尼迪克特，他们彼此之间是多么完全不同。绝对是。即使是相差不到两年的我的男孩们，在性格上也大不相同。而且成长经历几乎一模一样，你知道。我以前说过这个。
What's your take on this, Benedict? How much do you think is nature? How much do you think is nurture? Right? Because these three boys of yours, it's all nature, right? I mean, you can nurture, I think. Here we go, answering the question for the guest again, which I'd love to do. I think it's like five or ten percent you can move your kid, good or bad. Otherwise, you just, you get what you get. If they're going to be fantastic, they're fantastic. If they're going to be a challenge, they're going to be a challenge. You can have the best parents in the world and it's just you get what you get. What do you think? I don't know I think you're right about they arrive with something
你对此有什么看法，本尼迪克特？你认为多少是天性？多少是后天培养？对吧？因为你的这三个男孩，全是天性，对吧？我是说，你可以培养，我想。开始了，再次为嘉宾回答问题，我很乐意这样做。我认为这就像百分之五或十，你可以改变你的孩子，好或坏。否则，你只是，你得到什么就是什么。如果他们会很棒，他们就很棒。如果他们会是一个挑战，他们就是一个挑战。你可以拥有世界上最好的父母，但你得到什么就是什么。你怎么看？我不知道，我想你是对的，关于他们带着某种东西到来
that's beyond our understanding really there is this thing which if you're really open to it especially those first sort of five seven years and you present the world as a thing that's open and full of wonder and a safe place and full of magic as we very much know sometimes in reality it isn't but if you give them that space just to be themselves
这超出了我们的理解，真的有这样一种东西，如果你真的对它敞开心扉，特别是前五到七年，你把世界呈现为一个开放的、充满奇迹的、安全的地方，充满魔法，正如我们非常清楚的那样，有时在现实中它不是，但如果你给他们那个空间只是做他们自己，
you do see these extraordinary creatures just become something of their own accord. But I think it does need a lot of nurture and love. However, you know, you're right. Within that, they do things which are certainly to do with nature because how can a child give you love in a time of need as an adult, which I've experienced in my family and partly to do with the film we've got to talk about at some point,
你确实看到这些非凡的生物只是自发地变成了他们自己的样子。但我认为它确实需要大量的培养和爱。然而，你知道，你是对的。在其中，他们做的事情肯定与天性有关，因为一个孩子怎么能在成年人需要的时候给你爱，我在我的家庭中经历过，部分与我们必须在某个时候谈论的电影有关，
but, you know, it feels like it is, they are capable in the words of Max Porter in the novel of giving something back that isn't, it's not asked for it's not caused by anything other than them having an empathy or a link or an understanding of what love is that's human instinct that you're innately born with and yeah and I think without getting too
但是，你知道，感觉就像是，他们有能力用马克斯·波特在小说中的话来说，给予一些回报，这不是要求的，不是由任何其他原因引起的，除了他们拥有一种同理心或联系，或对什么是爱的理解，那是你天生就有的本能，是的，而且我认为如果不变得太
wishy-washy about it if I haven't already that is nature that is something that's sort of sent from somewhere else you start crying in the first 15 minutes we're going to have a problem Jason real quick empathy is yeah spell it
多愁善感的话，如果我还没那样做的话，那是天性，那是某种从别处发送来的东西。如果你在前15分钟就开始哭，我们会有麻烦的，杰森。快点，同理心是，是的，拼写它。
no I think it's yeah It's a mind-blower. It is a mind-blower. I'd have 12 kids if I could. Yeah, I think they're here to teach us, really. So, like you say, I think it is, I don't know about percentiles, but it's mostly nature. They are innertly, innately, not inertly,
不，我想它是，是的，这令人大开眼界。这确实令人大开眼界。如果可以的话，我会生12个孩子。是的，我认为他们来到这里是为了教导我们，真的。所以，就像你说的，我想它是，我不知道百分比，但主要是天性。他们是天生的，天生的，不是惰性的，
and very much actively wonderful gifts. Let's go back there with you, Benedict, your childhood. So you say you were an only child, and you were born to two actors, yes, mom and dad? Mom and dad, one, Van Them and Timothy Colton. That's amazing, right? It's so common on our show, too, when we have somebody as prolific as you
而且是非常积极的奇妙礼物。让我们回到那里，本尼迪克特，你的童年。所以你说你是独生子，你出生在两个演员家庭，是的，妈妈和爸爸？妈妈和爸爸，万·塞姆和蒂莫西·卡尔顿。这太神奇了，对吧？在我们节目中也很常见，当我们有像你这样多产的人时，
that it seems like they always come from an artist's family. Yeah, but rarely two actors, though, right? Usually they're sculptors or poets or something like that. So then I'm sure the answer would be no to the question of was there pressure to become an actor? It was probably just something that you were just naturally interested in because you saw your two first heroes doing that? A little. And also, I was, if anything, pressured the other way.
似乎他们总是来自艺术家家庭。是的，但很少有两个演员，对吧？通常他们是雕塑家或诗人之类的。所以我相信对于是否有压力成为演员这个问题，答案会是否定的。这可能只是你自然感兴趣的东西，因为你看到你的两个第一英雄在做那个？有一点。而且，如果说有什么的话，我反而受到了相反的压力。
Like, don't do what we're doing. It's a stupid way to spend a life. Look how peripatetic and uselessly we are at other things and how family life is a chaotic jumble of loose-end commitments that have to be abandoned at the last minute because Dad's got an advert audition. I mean, it was just, you know, they did really, really well in their careers. especially commercially. Dad, brilliantly as well in the theatre, he did a lot of the roll court in the early days of kitchen sink drama there. But the point is, you know,
比如，别做我们正在做的事。这是一种愚蠢的生活方式。看看我们在其他事情上是多么漂泊不定和无用，家庭生活是多么混乱的未竟承诺，必须在最后一刻放弃，因为爸爸有个广告试镜。我是说，这只是，你知道，他们在职业生涯中做得非常好。特别是商业上。爸爸，在剧院里也非常出色，他在厨房水槽剧的早期做了很多皇家宫廷剧。但重点是，你知道，
they wanted me to have the opportunities that they didn't, although they didn't have in their life as my parents. And they afforded me in education where I could have gone on to be a lawyer or something of that. That was the only other thing I flirted with, which is why I say that I did for a while. Sean flirted with a lawyer in the parking lot last night. and then I got to take the court for it
他们希望我有他们没有的机会，尽管他们作为我的父母在生活中没有。他们给了我一个教育，我可以去当律师或类似的事情。那是唯一我调情过的其他事情，这就是为什么我说我做了一段时间。肖恩昨晚在停车场和一位律师调情。然后我不得不为此上法庭。
but what do you mean they wanted but Benedict they wanted you have access to opportunity to something more predictable in your life career-wise I think it's something more stable definitely yeah and but the bug had bit really and it was very much to do with watching them and their prime doing doing what they did and I remember my dad in cast of noises off
但你是什么意思，他们想要，但本尼迪克特，他们想要你有机会获得职业生涯中更可预测的东西。我认为这更稳定，绝对是，是的，但那个虫子真的咬了，这很大程度上与看着他们处于巅峰状态做他们所做的事情有关，我记得我爸爸在《噪音关闭》的演员阵容中，
this amazing Michael frame play that's about, it's a farce within a farce. It's this amazingly kaleidoscopic, brilliant examination of a British tradition of comedy, which obviously you guys know called farce. My mum was doing the real thing, and even the real farses that were
这个惊人的迈克尔·弗雷恩剧，是关于，它是闹剧中的闹剧。这是对英国喜剧传统的一种令人惊叹的万花筒般的、辉煌的审视，显然你们知道叫闹剧。我妈妈在做真正的事情，甚至那些真正闹剧的
very duble entendre heavy, very misogynistic and homophobic at times as well to the point. I said, Mum, you really can't do another play where you walk into a room where your husband is having his pants pulled down by his male PA and it looks like fallatio. Whereas in fact he's just trying to give him a quick change
非常双关语沉重，非常厌女和恐同，有时甚至到了那种程度。我说，妈妈，你真的不能再演一部戏了，你走进一个房间，你的丈夫正被他的男性助理脱下裤子，看起来像口交。而事实上他只是想给他一个快速换装，
and his dress is stuck, I can't be your son and call myself proud if you keep doing this. But I do remember perversely to that embarrassment sort of sitting in the wings and watching her go through and just be mum and sort of chatting to me and saying hello to the SM and then just kind of opening the door and this light and heat and noise of what was happening in front of those flats hitting her and her just transforming, just in the blink of an eye
他的裙子卡住了，如果你继续这样做，我不能成为你的儿子并称自己为骄傲。但我确实记得，对那种尴尬的扭曲，坐在侧翼看着她经历，只是做妈妈，和我说说话，和舞台监督打招呼，然后只是打开门，那些平房前发生的事情的光、热和噪音击中她，她只是转变，眨眼之间，
And I thought, what is that? What just happened to my mom? Where did she go? And, yeah, I kind of got a taste for that. And as a only child, I think you're kind of already locked in a bit to quite a solitary, imaginary universe. When was it that you understood what they were kind of talking about when it comes to the career that you can't really count on? Like, how young were you? And do you remember that moment of going, yeah, but I get it's unpredictable.
我想，那是什么？我妈妈刚才发生了什么？她去哪了？而且，是的，我有点尝到了那个味道。作为独生子，我想你已经有点被锁定在一个相当孤独的、想象的宇宙中了。你是什么时候理解他们谈论的关于你无法真正指望的职业的？你当时多年轻？你还记得那一刻说，是的，但我明白它是不可预测的，
but I still want to go for it and try it. Numerous occasions. I'm too old to really remember. Still today. It's still today, exactly. Right, for all of us. I think a bit, yeah. Am I really doing this?
但我仍然想去争取并尝试它。无数次。我太老了，记不住了。直到今天。直到今天，完全正确。对，对我们所有人来说。我想有一点，是的。我真的在做这个吗？
Yeah, I'm doing it. You know, there were moments when I thought, okay, sage advice from ones who know, but I'm going to do it differently. I think I've got a different way into this. Yeah. And I don't know that it will be different. And in fact, really all I wanted was what they have,
是的，我在做。你知道，有那么一刻我想，好吧，来自知情者的明智建议，但我会以不同的方式去做。我想我有不同的进入方式。是的。而且我不知道它会不同。事实上，我真正想要的只是他们拥有的，
which is a career and respect from their peers and having a good time doing a job they love. You know, and that's what a great way to live your life. Yeah, yeah. You were chasing the right thing. So, you know, my way of doing it differently was perhaps going, okay, well, the things that you've done and you're like, maybe, I don't know, I don't know,
那就是职业生涯和同行的尊重，并且在做他们热爱的工作时玩得开心。你知道，这是一种多么伟大的生活方式。是的，是的。你在追求正确的事情。所以，你知道，我以不同方式做这件事的方法也许是说，好吧，你做过的事情，你就像，也许，我不知道，我不知道，
but I knew I was throwing, I knew I was throwing it to the wind, and I knew I was chancing it. But I think the moment I thought, I can't really not do this, is when I got serious, about A levels before going to college, a university in England, obviously. And, yeah, I met a lot of lawyers who are saying,
但我知道我在扔，我知道我在把它扔给风，我知道我在冒险。但我认为我想到，我真的不能不做这个的时刻，是当我认真对待A-level考试，在去大学之前，显然是在英国的大学。而且，是的，我遇到了很多律师说，
look, turn back now, people who are doing bar exams or people who had made it into being part of a chamber or even people practicing going, it's just, it's really pretty hard. It's an oversubscribed profession. It's very perpetrated. Yeah, you're only as good as your last case. I thought, that sounds very familiar.
看，现在回头吧，那些正在参加律师资格考试的人，或者那些已经成为律师事务所一部分的人，甚至那些正在执业的人说，这只是，这真的很难。这是一个超额认购的职业。这非常漂泊。是的，你只有上一件案子那么好。我想，这听起来很熟悉。
Why am I doing this, which would have acquired an inordinate amount of work on my part? I'm not that smart at all. And I would have had to work so hard for what? For as big a risk. But at least the credentials, the stuff you come out of college with, you are somewhat guaranteed a base salary and some future to it. Whereas with anything in the arts, you don't have that.
我为什么要这样做，这需要我付出巨大的努力？我一点也不聪明。我本来要为之付出这么多努力，为了什么？为了同样大的风险。但至少凭证，你从大学出来的东西，你多少保证有一个基本工资和一些未来。而在艺术界的任何事情，你都没有那个。
And so if one or two or three of your boys said, hey, I want to go into acting, would you, what would you as a father would you recommend that they dedicate the requisite number of years needed to kind of build a base or would you say ah what to have a backup you mean or put that time into something that is a bit more predictable where there's a guarantee you can count on yeah as a parent of course yeah because you worry about what the world will be let alone what their talent will be or won't be recognized as and where their ambitions and dreams are and their expectations of what the reality is and the gap between that.
所以如果你的三个男孩中的一个或两个或三个说，嘿，我想去演戏，你会，作为父亲你会建议他们投入建立基础所需的必要年数，还是你会说啊，为了有一个后备？你是说，或者把时间投入到更可预测的事情上，那里有你可以指望的保证？是的，作为父母，当然，是的，因为你担心世界会变成什么样，更不用说他们的才华会被认可还是不会被认可，以及他们的抱负和梦想是什么，他们对现实的期望是什么，以及两者之间的差距。
You never know that you're going to get to where you want to be. I'd tell my kids all the time, roll the dice. I'm always like, just roll the dice. Just fucking. I'm afraid, you know, I did it. I did it. So, well, how can I turn them away from something that I ended up doing? Actually, you know what's funny?
你永远不知道你会到达你想去的地方。我一直告诉我的孩子们，掷骰子。我总是说，只是掷骰子。只是他妈的。我害怕，你知道，我做到了。我做到了。所以，好吧，我怎么能把他们从我最终做的事情中拒之门外呢？其实，你知道什么很有趣？
You know what's funny, though? I will say, the difference now is, well, one of my sons, I think, is going to likely pursue something in the arts. And the other one is, yeah. And he's sort of leaning that way. And the other one is not, he's, and he was talking about some areas. And I said, here's the thing that they're talking about amongst their friends.
你知道什么很有趣吗？我会说，现在的区别是，嗯，我的一个儿子，我想，很可能会追求艺术方面的东西。另一个是，是的。他有点倾向于那个方向。另一个不是，他，他在谈论一些领域。我说，这是他们朋友之间谈论的事情。
He's, as my eldest son, he's a junior in high school here. So he's 17. He says, I said, they have to talk about what are the jobs out there going forward that are going to be affected by AI. And so kids are thinking about, like, you know, they don't want to become computer programmers or they're not going to become, you know, things like graphic design. Well, by the way, go down.
他，作为我的长子，他是这里高中的大三学生。所以他17岁。他说，我说，他们必须谈论未来哪些工作会受到人工智能的影响。所以孩子们在想，比如，你知道，他们不想成为计算机程序员，或者他们不会成为，你知道，像平面设计这样的事情。好吧，顺便说一句，下去吧。
Lawyers as well, legal work. All that stuff is going to be handled by AI. So now you're not competing against other kids. You're competing against the computers of the world. Right, right, right, right. I know, I know, I know. I don't envy them right now. And we're avoiding the fact that AI is massively in our industry as well.
律师也是，法律工作。所有这些东西都将由人工智能处理。所以现在你不是在和其他孩子竞争。你是在和世界上的计算机竞争。对，对，对，对。我知道，我知道，我知道。我现在不羡慕他们。而且我们正在回避人工智能在我们的行业中也大量存在的事实。
Oh, yeah. Exactly. Of course it is. Yeah, what's safe. All right. It's evening here. Can you see, I can't... It just got really dark there.
哦，是的。完全正确。当然是。是的，什么是安全的。好吧。这里是晚上。你能看到，我不能……那里变得非常黑。
It got really, really dark there. It's very moody. That's very nice. It's beautiful. Oh, nice. Now we can see you. Is that better? Oh, Benedict. Okay.
那里变得非常非常黑。这很有情绪。那很好。很美。哦，不错。现在我们可以看到你了。那样更好吗？哦，本尼迪克特。好吧。
Got it. Oh, it's Benedict. Oh, it's Benedict. Oh, it's better than Cover Batch. All right, so like Sweet Willie Arnett, you did some time in boarding school. Was that a positive experience or was it challenging? because I get homesick real easy that would be tough for me
明白了。哦，是本尼迪克特。哦，是本尼迪克特。哦，比康伯巴奇更好。好吧，所以像甜蜜的威利·阿内特一样，你在寄宿学校待过一段时间。那是一次积极的经历还是具有挑战性的？因为我很容易想家，那对我来说会很艰难。
how long have we got just the perfect mixture of both I'd say the first one was amazing I mean I'm an only child as I keep saying it I had a band of brothers for the first time in my life so that was that was easy street to 13
我们还有多久？我想是两者的完美结合。我想第一次很棒，我是说，我是独生子，正如我一直说的，我第一次在生活中拥有了一群兄弟，所以那是通往13岁的坦途。
and then the whole adolescence thing and it was a single sex one and it was at the sort of top of a hill looking down over the London basin and yet so oh so very far away from it and I just thought this isn't quite right this isn't real the demographic was very narrow and no girls and I just
然后是整个青春期的事情，那是单性别的，它位于伦敦盆地的山顶，俯瞰着它，却又离它那么远，我只是想这不太对，这不是真的，人口统计非常狭窄，没有女孩，我只是
the school itself was extraordinary some amazing teachers and fantastic experiences but at that point I was like okay the boarding thing I think I'm done with not because I was homesick but because I just I guess I wanted to be part of a broader community but that's a healthy thing there's also a very healthy thing to be straining away
学校本身非常非凡，有一些很棒的老师和奇妙的经历，但在那一点上，我当时想，好吧，寄宿的事情我想我受够了，不是因为我想家，而是因为我只是，我想我只是想成为更广泛社区的一部分，但那是一件健康的事情，这也是一件非常健康的事情，想要离开，
it was that was me leaving the nest I was already at home lever I guess at the age of eight I boarded when I was eight We'll be right back And now, back to the show Wait, so Bennett You were eight when you went away, yeah? Yeah, yeah
那是我就要离开巢穴了，我想我在八岁时就已经是个离家的人了，我八岁时就寄宿了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。等等，所以贝内特，你八岁时就离开了，是的？是的，是的。
How will be you? I was 12, but my roommate had come from When I was 12, I was in seventh grade, my roommate had just come from boarding school in England and he had been there since he was seven. Yeah. I bet you're easier when you go younger, right? will than when you're older because you just you've you've you've created those relationships
你多大？我12岁，但我的室友来自，当我12岁时，我在七年级，我的室友刚从英国的寄宿学校来，他从七岁起就在那里了。是的。我打赌你年轻时更容易，对吧？威尔，比你年长时，因为你只是，你已经创造了那些关系，
once you were way younger yes i mean i i'll sort of i'll sort of um jump on what benedict said which is you do create now i have siblings i have two older sisters and a younger brother quick what are their names and fucking garrie both days absolutely what's i'm saying are they yeah target tesco and tannis tannis and tannis and shaman or my sisters, and my brother's name is Chuck, aka Charles. So anyway, I was at boarding, but I went when I was 12, and you do have, and I'm still friends with some of those guys that I went to school with, because in those formative years,
一旦你年轻得多，是的，我是说，我会，我会，嗯，跳到本尼迪克特所说的，也就是你确实创造了，现在我有兄弟姐妹，我有两个姐姐和一个弟弟。快点，他们的名字是什么，该死，加里，两天，绝对是，我是说，他们是，是的，塔吉特，特斯科和坦尼斯，坦尼斯和坦尼斯和沙曼是我的姐妹，我兄弟的名字是查克，也就是查尔斯。所以无论如何，我在寄宿，但我12岁时去了，你确实有，而且我仍然和那些我一起上学的家伙是朋友，因为在那些形成期，
and I also was just all boys, when I went, it was all boys, it's now co-ed. But it is, you know, when I look back on it now, and I don't know how you feel about it, Benedict, but the idea of my boy is going away, there's no fucking way. Right, I know. I couldn't stand up. No, not unless they really want to, but no way, no way, no way.
而且我当时也全是男孩，当我去的时候，全是男孩，现在是男女同校。但它是，你知道，当我回顾它时，我不知道你对此感觉如何，本尼迪克特，但我的男孩离开的想法，绝对不可能。对，我知道。我站不住。不，除非他们真的想，但绝对不行，绝对不行，绝对不行。
And Sophie's the same mindset, you know, we do, yeah, and selfishly, I want them around. I want to be part of, even summer camp, whatever, whatever, however pushed away I am, I still want to be there in case the call comes, the fall happens, the need. Yeah, so can I ask a question to the group here? Yeah. Because I don't have a kid. Just one kid. Let me look at the clock real quick.
苏菲也是同样的心态，你知道，我们确实，是的，而且自私地说，我想要他们在身边。我想成为一部分，即使是夏令营，无论什么，无论我被推开多少，我仍然想在那里，以防电话打来，跌倒发生，需要。是的，所以我可以问小组一个问题吗？是的。因为我没有孩子。只有一个孩子。让我快速看一下时钟。
Yeah, if you make it quick, yes. Yeah, Benedict, get comfortable. This is going to be a long question. Oh, shit. It took his jacket off. When you asked a question. It's hot on here. No, is what is the, because I don't know about boarding school, why would a parent send their kid to boarding school?
是的，如果你快点，是的。是的，本尼迪克特，舒服点。这将是一个很长的问题。哦，该死。他脱掉了夹克。当你问一个问题时。这里很热。不，是，因为我不知道寄宿学校，为什么父母会把孩子送到寄宿学校？
Better education, focus. Okay. Yes, question? Amazing facilities. Very immersive educational experience where you have, well, the beginning of it only where you have a very structured timetable. So there's sort of purpose to, your day. It's very
更好的教育，专注。好吧。是的，问题？惊人的设施。非常沉浸式的教育体验，你有，嗯，只有开始时，你有非常结构化的时间表。所以你的日子有某种目的。它非常
fulfilling. God, I sound like a brochure. Yeah, because it always sounds like a jail or something. No, no. They're very plush places. It's like Hogwarts. It's like incredible. Yeah. Oh, I'm in. That is exactly how it was described once by Martin Freeman. He said, I went to a North school and Benedict
充实。天哪，我听起来像个宣传册。是的，因为它听起来总是像监狱之类的。不，不。它们是非常豪华的地方。就像霍格沃茨。就像不可思议。是的。哦，我加入了。那正是马丁·弗里曼曾经描述的那样。他说，我去了北方的学校，本尼迪克特
went to Hogwarts, which I kind of did. It wasn't a wizard school, but it was a particularly old one. It is, but it is true. And, you know, think about all those things. You learn how to, you know, by the time I got to college age, I dropped out quickly from college but and part of it was because
去了霍格沃茨，我确实有点像。那不是巫师学校，但它是一个特别古老的学校。它是，但它是真的。而且，你知道，想想所有那些事情。你学会了如何，你知道，当我到了大学年龄时，我很快从大学退学了，但部分原因是
everybody my peers who were there who did not go to boarding school it was their first time away from home and I'd been away from home so so much earlier that getting out I was ready to get out of the world I was like I'm ready to go yeah yeah I've been
所有我的同龄人，那些没有去寄宿学校的人，那是他们第一次离开家，而我离开家早得多，所以出来时，我准备好离开世界了，我当时想，我准备好走了，是的，是的，我已经
looking after having a frat party and like isn't it cool to party yeah and you're like no I've already done this true true true and I think I don't know I'm here and I've come of it okay and i wouldn't really change it i wouldn't know what i'd change it too i didn't have any other experience but like jason who taught you how to tie a tie oh that would have been
照顾好，举办了一个兄弟会派对，就像派对不是很酷吗，是的，你就像，不，我已经做过这个了，真的，真的，我想我不知道，我在这里，我从中走出来了，还好，我真的不会改变它，我不知道我会把它改成什么，我没有任何其他经历，但像杰森，谁教你打领带的？哦，那会是
or a set dresser uh the set on set costumer for rest of development is that true really no really but i i did really nail it down on that because i had to tie a tie every freaking day and then loosen it and then loosen and then roll up the sleeves roll up the sleeve because michael bluth can i just something just as an aside Michael Bluth this guy well he got down well he got down to business
或者一个布景师，呃，发展受阻的布景服装师，那是真的吗？真的吗？不，真的，但我确实在那个方面把它钉死了，因为我必须每天打领带，然后松开它，然后松开，然后卷起袖子，卷起袖子，因为迈克尔·布鲁斯，我可以只是作为一个旁白，迈克尔·布鲁斯，这家伙，好吧，他做得很好，他做得很好，
he was rolling up those sleeves if you go back and you watch Jason push his sleeves until to this day well you've given me a full complex about that because that's just that's just Jason
他卷起了那些袖子，如果你回去看杰森推他的袖子，直到今天，好吧，你给了我一个完整的情结，因为那只是，那只是杰森，
that's not Michael Bluth it's just I always roll up my sleeves on a button down shirt and I still do it to this day and I think it I hear your stupid fucking GMC voice every morning
那不是迈克尔·布鲁斯，只是我总是卷起我的衬衫袖子，直到今天我仍然这样做，我想我每天早上都能听到你愚蠢的该死的GMC声音，
when I roll up my sleeves getting down the business you're thinking stupid fuck all right now how long of you two know each of was that when you two first met on arrested development
当我卷起袖子开始工作时，你在想愚蠢的混蛋，好吧，现在你们两个认识多久了，那是你们两个第一次在《发展受阻》见面吗？
I think so too long yeah and now we're stuck on this podcasting so now you must have loved you guys it's such a blast being out I have to say
我想也是，太久了，现在我们被困在这个播客上了，所以现在你们一定很喜欢你们这些家伙，我不得不说，出来真是太棒了。
I'm a huge huge fan of this show and it's just it's one of these things one of my best friends put me on to he said if you got to hear I mean I love all of your work individually but yeah it's a very good thing you've got going here it's fantastic now listen back to you you must have enjoyed the education at the boarding school enough when i said that well you've
我是这个节目的超级超级粉丝，这真的是我最好的朋友之一推荐给我的，他说你一定要听听，我是说我非常喜欢你们每个人的作品，但你们在这里做的这个节目真的很棒，太精彩了。现在回到你身上，你一定很享受在寄宿学校接受的教育，当我这么说的时候，嗯，你
become you've become a teacher yourself and you teach english what in a Tibetan community what's untrue just outside of Dajarling India yeah yes I like that um especially the pronunciation I said, de Jarling, that's the idea. No, I was... How do you say it? How do you say it? We should all now say it, Dejarling. Wait, what is it? How do you say it? Did you go to Dejaling, darling?
你自己也成为了一名老师，你在一个藏族社区教英语，是在印度大吉岭郊外，对吧？是的，我喜欢这个，尤其是发音，我说“Dejarling”，就是这个意思。不，我是……你怎么说？你怎么说？我们现在都应该说“Dejarling”。等等，是什么？你怎么说？你去大吉岭了吗，亲爱的？
No, Darjeeling, I think. Darjeeling, that's it. Dergieling. Did you go to Dejarling? No, I didn't have the de time. It's great. My dad has this habit of doing... He says, oh, I think I'm going to go to Marks and Spencers and buy a miles bar.
不，我想是Darjeeling（大吉岭）。Darjeeling，就是那个。Dergieling。你去大吉岭了吗？不，我没那个时间。这太棒了。我爸爸有个习惯……他说，哦，我想去玛莎百货买根Miles巧克力棒。
Dad, what? You're a trait. actor what did i do well every summer in a biza i i i like to de jay you know for like a week or two i'll go down there to jay wow so so so jay so jay so so it is true wait so you're taught you taught english in a taboo community yeah i mean it's a very loose term i kind of turned up and they giggled at me which was fair enough cultural exchange well no it was very often i learned i learned I learned so much. As you can imagine, I was a 19-year-old kid who knew nothing who'd come from a very kind of, you know, enclosed private school, you know, boarding school education. And it was the first talk at the school that we had given to us. This has got a school I went to. We got given talks about what you could do with your year out if you wanted to take one between school and university and college. Yeah, a little gap year. Exactly. And it was the first one I heard about and I just went.
爸爸，什么？你是个演员，我做了什么？好吧，每年夏天在伊比萨岛，我喜欢去当DJ，你知道，大概一两周，我会去那里打碟。哇，所以，所以，所以，所以是真的。等等，所以你教过藏族社区的英语？是的，我是说这是一个非常宽泛的说法，我去了那里，他们对我咯咯笑，这也很公平，文化交流。好吧，不，我学到了很多，我学到了很多。你可以想象，我当时是一个19岁的孩子，什么都不懂，来自那种非常封闭的私立寄宿学校教育。这是我们在学校听到的第一次讲座。这是我上的学校。我们听了关于如果你想在高中和大学之间休学一年，你可以做什么的讲座。是的，间隔年。没错。这是我听到的第一个，我就去了。
I didn't really listen to it being about teaching. It was all about being close to Tibetan culture. I just had this very strong gravitational pull in my soul. I thought, I have to do this. There's nothing. I know people are, well, don't you want to volunteer in Africa? Don't you want to climb a mountain? All these amazing opportunities.
我并没有真正听进去关于教学的内容。这完全是关于接近藏族文化。我的灵魂深处有一种非常强烈的吸引力。我想，我必须这样做。没什么。我知道人们会说，难道你不想去非洲做志愿者吗？难道你不想去爬山吗？所有这些绝佳的机会。
And I just was deaf to all of them because of how strongly I felt I needed to do this. What was the pull to the Tibetan culture? When did that start? Yeah, I don't know. Maybe in a previous lifetime. I really don't know. I mean, I was fascinated by it visually and I knew a bit about Buddhism
但我对所有这些都充耳不闻，因为我感到我必须这样做。是什么吸引你走向藏族文化？那是什么时候开始的？是的，我不知道。也许是在前世吧。我真的不知道。我是说，我在视觉上被它吸引，而且我对佛教也了解一点。
but it was just so overwhelming and as was the experience I had there was six months of, well, five months of teaching and then some tourism tied to the end. Wandering about India and Nepal which was both of which were extraordinary and any poll from Everest at all? Was that part of the poll at all?
但这太令人震撼了，我在那里的经历也是如此，有五个月的教学，然后最后还有一些旅游。在印度和尼泊尔四处游荡，这两个地方都非常非凡。从珠穆朗玛峰那里有什么吸引力吗？那是吸引力的一部分吗？
Because I've got this fascination with Everest but would that part of it should we do it I'd like I'll do it yeah I want to get at least a base camp in my lifetime I would but you know
因为我对珠峰有一种迷恋，但那是其中的一部分吗？我们应该去吗？我想我会去的，是的，我这辈子至少想去一次大本营，我会的，但是你知道，
then you hear about how much pollution there is how much tourism and craziness there is and I kind of go well maybe there's a better mountain to walk down then what watch watch how quickly
然后你听说那里有多少污染，有多少旅游和疯狂，我就想，也许有更好的山可以走，那么，看着，看着我们能多快
we can turn Jason off Everest do you know how dirty it is Jason wait what yeah and the tents the tents are really dirty I just shower every night you know
把杰森从珠峰上赶下来。你知道那里有多脏吗，杰森？等等，什么？是的，帐篷，帐篷真的很脏。我每晚都洗澡，你知道，
they don't have showers they don't change the linens no they don't change the linens you can't use sanitizer there's no ring that out that would be scary yeah yeah
他们没有淋浴，他们不换床单，不，他们不换床单，你不能用消毒剂，没有那个，那太可怕了，是的，是的，
but all right so that was sorry it wasn't the landscape did have a pull in all seriousness of course it did it's such an extraordinary bit of geography
但是好吧，所以那是，抱歉，不是风景，说真的，它确实有吸引力，当然有，那里的地理环境太非凡了，
that whole area and this is in the foothills so going towards Darjeeling and it's a little hill station town called Sanada and it was a
整个区域，这是在山脚下，所以朝着大吉岭方向，那是一个叫萨纳达的小山站城镇，它是一个
converted Nepali house and at the top was this monastery this prayer room below was the monk's accommodation the eating area and then a small
改造过的尼泊尔房子，顶层是这个寺庙，祈祷室，下面是僧侣的住所、用餐区，然后是一个小的
teaching area and I might have got the height or numbers of levels wrong but I was basically very much on the bottom and it was really we were high up in what 4,000 metres something like that and you open the window and it was
教学区，我可能记错了高度或层数，但我基本上是在最底层，我们真的很高，大概4000米左右，你打开窗户，
sort of coming into autumn and winter there so the clouds would literally roll in like dry ice through the window it was absolutely extraordinary and pretty basic my dad reminded me his panic this is pre-cell phones I'm that old and the internet as well I'm that old
那里快到秋天和冬天了，所以云会像干冰一样从窗户滚进来，这绝对是非凡的，而且非常简陋。我爸爸提醒我，他的恐慌，这是在手机之前，我老了，还有互联网，我也老了，
and it was a moment where I'd written in tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny, tiny scrawl on a blue airmail letter home one weekend. Don't worry, Dad, all the cold is solved now in my room as I have a gas heater and I've managed to block all the vents and he was reading it and going to go, oh my God, he's going to die of carbon monoxide poison. Yeah. I didn't, but, you know, might explain a few brain cells less that I have now, but it was very basic but very romantic, very hard, very lonely,
那是一个周末，我在一封蓝色的航空信上用极小极小的字迹写信回家。别担心，爸爸，我房间里的寒冷现在解决了，因为我有一个煤气加热器，我已经设法堵住了所有的通风口，他读着信，心想，天哪，他会死于一氧化碳中毒。是的。我没有，但是，你知道，这可能解释了我现在脑细胞少了一些，但它非常简陋，但非常浪漫，非常艰难，非常孤独，
very elating, very inspiring, and spiritually, mind-blowing, and utterly mundane. And it was just a really... How do you clean yourself? Sorry, Benedict. Like, how do you... We're talking about how many days... How many days are you out there? Sean's talking to somebody off camera.
非常令人振奋，非常鼓舞人心，精神上令人震撼，而且极其平凡。这只是一个非常……你怎么清洁自己？抱歉，本尼迪克特。就像，你怎么……我们正在谈论多少天……你在外面待了多少天？肖恩正在和镜头外的人说话。
He's setting up the weekend. He's talking to his dog licking its balls. How do you do that? We all want to know, Sean. We all want to know. I'll show you. That's my teaching class. That's my teaching class.
他正在安排周末。他正在和他的狗说话，狗在舔它的蛋蛋。你怎么做到的？我们都想知道，肖恩。我们都想知道。我会给你看的。那是我的教学班。那是我的教学班。
He's talking to somebody off camera. Show me after. When I'm done, I'm doing the podcast and show me. Sean, your mic's still hot. I can't wait to see. Show you, show me after. No, I'm recording a podcast. I'm doing it now, but you start.
他正在和镜头外的人说话。结束后给我看。等我做完，我正在做播客，结束后给我看。肖恩，你的麦克风还在开着。我迫不及待想看了。给你看，结束后给我看。不，我正在录播客。我现在正在做，但你开始吧。
Start now. They can't see. Start. Okay. Wait, I want to know the answer. Back to business. What the fuck? What was your question about?
现在开始。他们看不见。开始。好吧。等等，我想知道答案。回到正题。什么鬼？你的问题是关于什么的？
How do I clean myself? Yeah. Even the real... In general, or... But a small street in a happily house. No, when you... With melted snow.
我怎么清洁自己？是的。通常情况下，或者……但在一个快乐的房子里的小街道。不，当你……用融化的雪。
When you're out there in a tent for what day's weeks? What do you do? No. No, no, no. I was in a house. I was in a house. Oh, next question. He's filling in for someone this week, Benedict.
当你待在帐篷里，几天还是几周？你做什么？不。不，不，不。我在房子里。我在房子里。哦，下一个问题。他这周在替别人，本尼迪克特。
I thought you were in a tent. Is it a zipper or buttons? Is it a zipper or buttons? Show me, is it? Do you need a lufa back there? Scotty, get the lufa. All right, so let's move to that. Now, so we're back from Dejarling,
我以为你在帐篷里。是拉链还是扣子？是拉链还是扣子？给我看，是吗？你需要在那后面用丝瓜络吗？斯科蒂，拿丝瓜络来。好吧，那我们继续。现在，我们从大吉岭回来了，
and we're going to make a... The DJ. We're back from you, DJ. And we're going to make a career of this acting thing. And we're going to go for the acting, and we get a little bit of momentum going, and we're on our first film set. Which is...
我们要……那个DJ。我们从你那里回来了，DJ。我们要把演戏当成职业。我们要去演戏，我们有了一点动力，我们正在拍摄第一部电影。那是……
That's a fucking long way into the story, but maybe the only bit's boring. To kill a king. Is that a first feature film role? Yes? I don't remember. Maybe that was my first feature. But do you remember what that first, being on a set for the first time,
那离故事开始还有很长一段路，但也许唯一的部分很无聊。《杀掉国王》。那是你的第一部电影角色吗？是吗？我不记得了。也许那是我的第一部电影。但你还记得第一次在片场的感觉吗，
how did that, how did that jive with what you had, you'd gone through all this great theater education, acting education, and then you're on a set and you see all the equipment and you're just doing little bits at a time as opposed to theater. Like, how did that strike you, this film process? I just remember, I remember small snippets. of Du Grace Scott being very lovely and serious and smoky voiced. I remember Julian Ryan Tuck being very sort of funny and witty
那和你经历过的所有伟大的戏剧教育、表演教育有什么冲突吗？然后你在片场，你看到所有的设备，你一次只做一点点，而不是戏剧。就像，这电影制作过程给你什么感觉？我只记得，我记得杜格雷·斯科特的一些小片段，非常可爱、严肃，声音沙哑。我记得朱利安·莱恩·塔克非常风趣、机智，
and just being incredibly on it. And me laughing quite a lot. I don't remember anything that I did in front of camera. I didn't come away going, oh, wow, yeah, okay, camera work. Interesting. Not because it was a bad experience. I'm being genuine about my lack of memory of that particular experience. You don't remember being scolded for looking at the camera?
而且非常专注。我笑得很多。我不记得我在镜头前做了什么。我没有走开时说，哦，哇，是的，好吧，摄像工作。有趣。不是因为那是一次糟糕的经历。我对自己在那次特定经历中记忆的缺失是真诚的。你不记得因为看镜头而被训斥了吗？
Did I? Maybe I have, maybe you've spoken to the director. No, no, no. That would be, that would be my fault. Well, no, so, I mean, I guess, well, two things. I suppose mum and dad helped in that regard a little bit, not because they rehearsed me or anything like that, and I think stage mummy, but just, I guess I was a little bit aware of what you do and don't do on a set, having been on a couple where they were doing their thing.
我有吗？也许我有，也许你和导演谈过。不，不，不。那会是，那会是我的错。好吧，不，所以，我是说，我想，好吧，两件事。我想爸爸妈妈在这方面帮了一点忙，不是因为他们排练我什么的，我想是舞台妈妈，但我猜我有点意识到在片场该做什么和不该做什么，因为我待过几个他们正在做他们事情的片场。
But also, and funny enough, I'd been, my first ever film job, TV job, was in Heartbeat, which is an ITV staple, or was. in England a very nostalgic police drama set on the Yorkshire Dales and was at the Moors
而且，有趣的是，我曾经，我的第一份电影工作，电视工作，是在《心跳》中，这是ITV的主打剧，或者曾经是。在英国，这是一部非常怀旧的警察剧，背景在约克郡谷地，是在荒原上，
sorry Yorkshire God Olivia did this when she was talking to you about Devon and Devon and Dorset is Devon by the way that's what we've done see I do listen to your show
抱歉，约克郡，天哪，奥利维亚在和你谈论德文郡和多塞特郡时做了这个，顺便说一句，德文郡就是这样，这就是我们所做的，看，我确实听了你的节目，
and I just remember being very nervous on heartbeat set I do remember that very very well and just wondering am I any good I don't know what I'm doing And I know there's something capturing everything I'm doing. I'm like an audience which has this kind of multi-camera perspective.
我只记得在《心跳》片场非常紧张，我记得非常非常清楚，只是想我演得好吗？我不知道我在做什么。我知道有什么东西在捕捉我所做的一切。我像是一个观众，有这种多机位视角。
And you can't watch yourself back. You can. And I really wanted to, but I didn't. But I kind of wanted to know, what the fuck am I doing? What am I doing too much, too little? Because you didn't get any feedback as you were used to from like an audience, you know, from doing theater. Was that it? No.
你不能回看自己。你可以。我真的很想，但我没有。但我有点想知道，我到底在做什么？我做得太多还是太少？因为你没有得到像戏剧那样来自观众的反馈，你知道吗？是那样吗？不。
No, none. Because it's just a very, you know, well-oiled machine, a crew that I've been doing it for literally decades. And, yeah, it was just very kind of, oh, well, I hope that's all right. I hope I get to work again, you know. And it was the first job I got. I was still at drama school, so I had to ask permission. I was only at Lambda for one year, but I had to ask permission to do the job. You're not supposed to work if you're still out of drama school.
不，什么都没有。因为这只是一个非常，你知道，运转良好的机器，一个已经做了几十年这种工作的剧组。而且，是的，只是非常，哦，好吧，希望那没问题。希望我能再有工作，你知道。这是我得到的第一份工作。我还在戏剧学校，所以我不得不请求许可。我在兰达只待了一年，但我不得不请求许可去做这份工作。如果你还在戏剧学校，你不应该工作。
Yeah. I don't know if that's changed. I hope it has in many ways. Now, you mentioned not being able to see yourself back. I ask actors this. do you watch yourself act and if so have you have you uh treated yourself to looking at your older work and do you see a big difference between how you used to act versus today and is that a is that a is that a do you do you applaud yourself for having gotten better different how so
是的。我不知道这是否改变了。我希望它在很多方面都改变了。现在，你提到了不能回看自己。我问演员这个问题。你看自己演戏吗？如果是的话，你有没有……你有没有犒劳自己去看你早期的作品？你看到你过去演戏的方式和今天有很大区别吗？这是一个……这是一个……你是否为自己变得更好而鼓掌？不同之处在哪里？
smaller bigger do you do you do that do you watch you no no i'm not i'm not my own my own sort of crazy fan and i don't mean that in a sort of it's only vanity that does that it is that could be an incredibly useful thing to do but i'm not quite that for me it is yeah i'm not a precision tool in that way i i kind of um no i'm not going to compare myself to what i have done it's always about where i'm at at the moment and that the the the need to see some reflection of what what is going on is it registering and also to have that conversation with the director going and i think i think i know what you wanted and i was trying to do something else can we can we go again so i can try and give you something nearer what you want.
更小还是更大？你做那个吗？你看吗？不，不，我不是，我不是我自己的那种疯狂粉丝，我不是说这只是虚荣心，这可能是一件非常有用的事情，但我不是那样的人。对我来说，是的，我不是那种精密工具。我……不，我不会拿自己和过去做比较。这总是关于我当下的状态，以及看到正在发生的事情的某种反映的需要，它是否在注册，以及与导演进行那种对话，说，我想我知道你想要什么，我试图做点别的，我们可以再来一次吗，这样我可以试着给你一些更接近你想要的东西。
I've seen now that that's not quite, that doesn't quite fit it. And for the character and the movement and whatever it is, I mean, it's a really hard thing to generalise about. Yeah, yeah. I guess I've been stretched like gum in all sorts of directions as an actor. So I can't really be specific. Certain things, like I think Power of the Dog, I never, I don't think I ever watched a play back on that
我现在看到那不太对，那不太合适。对于角色和动作以及其他任何事情，我是说，概括这一点真的很难。是的，是的。我想我作为演员像口香糖一样被拉向了各个方向。所以我不能具体说明。某些事情，比如我认为《犬之力》，我从来没有，我不认为我回看过那部电影，
because I just, I knew I was in and either it was shit or it was happening. and I just had to just be that guy anyway. So kind of going around as Phil Burbank going, can I see the playback, you know, being an asshole about it, I didn't really want to have that interaction with crew. And I wanted to have the arrogance of the character. Well, you strike me as somebody who's skilled enough, talented enough, and touch with yourself enough to really be able to direct yourself
因为我只是，我知道我在里面，要么是烂片，要么是正在发生的。我只需要成为那个家伙。所以像菲尔·伯班克那样到处走，说，我能看回放吗，你知道，表现得像个混蛋，我真的不想和剧组有那种互动。我想拥有那个角色的傲慢。好吧，你给我的印象是一个足够熟练、足够有天赋，并且足够了解自己的人，真的能够指导自己
to a certain extent and know whether it's good or bad. How much do you defer to a director? You mentioned, you know, well, I know what you want to. So let me do another one to see if I can do what you. Will you shape a performance for a director? Will you do what a director wants you to do? What is your opinion on that? Like, whose character is it?
在一定程度上，知道它是好是坏。你多大程度上听从导演？你提到了，你知道，好吧，我知道你想要什么。所以让我再来一次，看看我能不能做你想要的。你会为导演塑造表演吗？你会做导演想让你做的事吗？你对此有什么看法？就像，这是谁的角色？
I think I've been very, very lucky with the caliber of director. Well, thank you for what you just said, first of all. But I also think it is about how lucky I've been with the caliber of director. You know, I form trust with that person. And so therefore can filter my own, in a sense of whether I was shit or good, bad, bad, or indifferent. and match it to their honesty about it. And the best directors as well often give you a prompt that turns everything around 180 degrees.
我想我在导演的水平上非常非常幸运。好吧，首先谢谢你刚才说的话。但我也认为这关乎我有多幸运，能遇到这种水平的导演。你知道，我和那个人建立了信任。因此，可以在某种意义上过滤我自己，关于我是烂还是好，坏，坏，还是无所谓，并将其与他们对此的诚实相匹配。最好的导演也经常给你一个提示，把一切都扭转180度。
And it's not that they've rejected what you've done or didn't like it. They just want to see something different. That's what excites me. It's just trying to jump through a different hoop in a way. Do you remember the first time as you were coming up after you kind of got your sea legs about you and acting your first gigs?
并不是他们拒绝了你所做的或者不喜欢它。他们只是想看到不同的东西。这就是让我兴奋的地方。这就像试图以某种方式跳过不同的圈。你还记得你第一次，当你刚开始适应并演戏，你的第一份工作时吗？
Do you remember the first time when you took a real, big swing and you're like oh god this is something i never imagined i could do and it scares the shit out of me i think a little bit on every every job but i i it's to one degree or another um really big that's a really good question shown you do take great swings and you you you never clank it you always hit the ball hard yeah he's really admirable like you always feel like you're in great hands as an audience member when when when you're watching oh thank you yeah truly that's a huge coming from you guys thank you no it's it's and whether it's drama or comedy it's it's pretty impressive thank you um well i i i i guess the the bottom line is there's no sort of secret source
你还记得第一次你做了一个真正的大胆尝试，你心想，天哪，这是我从未想象过我能做到的，这吓坏我了。我想在每一份工作上都有那么一点点，但我……在某种程度上……真的很大，这是一个很好的问题，肖恩。你确实做了大胆的尝试，你从来没有搞砸，你总是用力击球。是的，他真的很令人钦佩，就像你作为观众在观看时总是觉得你在很好的手中。哦，谢谢。是的，真的，这对你们来说意义重大，谢谢。不，这是……无论是戏剧还是喜剧，这都令人印象深刻。谢谢。嗯，我……我……我猜底线是，没有所谓的秘密配方
to it i feel yeah i feel excited when i'm taking a big swing um when did i first feel that sense of oh i'm not sure i can do this oh well i i know is that well that that sorry no go well it was i was just going to say it was one of those reactions where i've got i've got the job and then i thought oh my god how am i going to do that yeah and that was that was playing stephen hawking in a television drama about his life right which sort of compared to eddies took it up to you know he was walking with a stick and that the speech was very impaired um still married to jane hawking so it was a very it was one slice of his life his extraordinary life and um yeah the thrill the elation of that and then going oh my god i've just convinced people that i can do this i don't think i can you know
对此，我感到，是的，当我做大胆尝试时，我感到兴奋。嗯，我第一次感到那种“哦，我不确定我能做到”的感觉是什么时候？哦，好吧，我知道，那是……抱歉，不，继续。好吧，我只是想说，那是那种反应之一，我得到了工作，然后我想，天哪，我该怎么做？是的，那就是扮演斯蒂芬·霍金，在一部关于他生活的电视剧中，对吧？这与埃迪的相比，把它提升到了，你知道，他拄着拐杖走路，说话非常受损……仍然嫁给简·霍金，所以这是他生活、他非凡生活的一个片段，而且……是的，那种快感，那种兴奋，然后心想，天哪，我刚刚说服人们我能做到这一点，我不认为我能，你知道。
I was immediately terrified after the 10 seconds of elation. So I guess that was the first moment where I thought, well, this is kind of a big swing. Yeah. But what was that first, what was that first, that first moment where you, so I totally get that and relate to that. But then the moment.
在10秒的快感之后，我立刻感到恐惧。所以我猜那是第一个让我觉得，好吧，这算是一个大胆尝试的时刻。是的。但那是什么，那是什么，那个时刻，你……所以我完全理解并感同身受。但那个时刻。
But I think, I think Sean's question was more about, you were talking about choices. I mean, within the performance. He was talking about choices, but when do you feel comfortable? When was that first time you felt? Forget Sean's question. He's, when was that first time that you felt,
但我认为，我认为肖恩的问题更多是关于，你在谈论选择。我是说，在表演之内。他在谈论选择，但你什么时候感到舒服？那是你第一次感到……忘记肖恩的问题。他……那是你第一次感到……
that you felt comfortable in a performance where you, because you know there's that thing when you're a young actor and you go in and you're just, sometimes you're like, I don't want to fuck up, or you're just kind of, you're nervous and blah, blah, blah. And then what's that first moment where you felt like? Rather than going, oh, hell. Yeah, you hit a groove, you felt tight, you got it, you know. Do you remember that job?
你在表演中感到舒服，因为你知道当你是一个年轻演员时，你进去，你只是……有时你会想，我不想搞砸，或者你只是有点……你很紧张，等等等等。然后那是你第一次感到……而不是说，哦，天哪。是的，你进入了状态，你感到紧凑，你做到了，你知道。你还记得那份工作吗？
No, I think that was what Sean was saying. Oh, I'm back in. You're back in? Oh, please, but I do. I do think that's what you meant. I think, I don't know, it's so hard, it's so hard to be specific about this sort of thing. Fuck, I don't know.
不，我想那正是肖恩所说的。哦，我回来了。你回来了？哦，拜托，但我确实。我确实认为那是你的意思。我想，我不知道，很难，很难具体说明这种事情。该死，我不知道。
I'm always saying to acting students that I feel you can have, you can have something very theatrical in a close-up as much as you can have something very myopically focused and close-up on the stage. I think the magnification of a performance is really to do, if something is too big,
我总是对表演系学生说，我觉得你可以，你可以在特写镜头中拥有非常戏剧性的东西，就像你可以在舞台上拥有非常近视的焦点和特写一样。我认为表演的放大确实与……如果某件事太大，
It means often it's wrong. It doesn't mean that the scale of it is, what am I trying to say? I don't know. Some big choices I made where I thought, I'm just doing this, and I think it's right. I mean, Patrick Melrose would probably be one because I've partied, but that guy was at other level. And I think the choices I made with him were pretty committed.
通常意味着它是错的。这并不意味着它的规模是……我试图说什么？我不知道。我做过一些大的选择，我心想，我只是在做这个，我认为它是对的。我是说，帕特里克·梅尔罗斯可能是一个，因为我参加过派对，但那个家伙在另一个水平。我认为我对他做的选择非常投入。
And I, you know, because I was in a very sober state doing, this crazy different levels of inebriated dance work I kind of just I just really committed to it and it's those things where you go I think this could you know I didn't I don't even remember thinking this could be silly I actually remember thinking it was quite fun yeah maybe I should try quailudes and I'm joking I just had a I had a commitment to it that meant it felt like I was on the ride but also thinking I hope this actually works I think we have that a lot
而且，你知道，因为我处于一种非常清醒的状态，做这种疯狂的、不同程度的醉酒舞蹈工作，我只是……我只是真的投入其中，就是那些你心想，我想这可能……你知道，我甚至不记得想过这可能很傻，我实际上记得认为它很有趣。是的，也许我应该试试安眠酮，我在开玩笑。我只是对它有一种投入，这意味着感觉我正在经历这一切，但也心想，希望这真的有效。我想我们经常有那种感觉，
don't we when we're having a good time doing something as well going okay this feels great and everyone here is enjoying it and we're all but is anyone going to watch it or think the same or yeah people that aren't obligated to say hey great job yeah you're fully reliant on
不是吗？当我们做某事玩得很开心时，也会想，好吧，这感觉很棒，这里的每个人都很享受，我们都在……但有人会看它或有同样的想法吗？或者，你知道，那些没有义务说“嘿，干得好”的人。是的，你完全依赖于
on a biased audience and it's a little bit scary and I think to your point about directors you can come out of an experience and go oh should I really do need to trust my voice and my instincts a little bit more sometimes because I think I could have got that better. I have had moments watching things soon after their completion and gone, yeah, I should have dug my heels about that.
一个有偏见的观众，这有点可怕。我认为关于导演，你可以从一次经历中走出来，心想，哦，我真的需要更多地相信我的声音和直觉，有时因为我认为我可以做得更好。我在完成某事后不久观看它们时，有过那种时刻，心想，是的，我应该坚持到底。
Yeah, yeah. The best take or the best choice of acting. Yeah, but you were not foolish to count on the taste of people like San Mandis or Thomas Alfredson. Like I said, some amazing directors. Yeah. We'll be right back. and now back to the show
是的，是的。最好的表演或最好的表演选择。是的，但你并不愚蠢，去指望像萨姆·门德斯或托马斯·阿尔弗莱德森这样的人的品味。就像我说的，一些了不起的导演。是的。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。
speaking of tinker taylor soldier spy what about the fear of of acting with those incredible actors around you like was was was that nerve wracking mean you were obviously very very well established by the time you did that film but still you can't shake the little guy who was at lambda you know like you're sitting there with with these titans was that uh was that frightening yeah i mean uh yeah the first time i met um i mean mark i'd done a little thing with mark strong so i knew him Colin was just absurdly wonderful and lovely and nice and goofy and impressionable as well as being ridiculously smart and talented uh and devilishly handsome and all the rest of he is and then
说到《锅匠，裁缝，士兵，间谍》，关于和那些不可思议的演员一起演戏的恐惧，就像……那是令人紧张的吗？我是说，当你拍那部电影时，你显然已经非常非常成熟了，但你仍然无法摆脱那个在兰达的小家伙，你知道，就像你坐在那里，和这些巨人在一起，那是……那是令人恐惧的吗？是的，我是说……是的，我第一次见到……我是说马克，我和马克·斯特隆做过一点小事，所以我认识他。科林简直是荒谬地美妙、可爱、友善，而且天真，同时又极其聪明和有才华，而且邪恶地英俊，所有这些他都是。然后
gary when i first met gary he walked around the corner of it was either working titles office or it was somewhere uninspiring and it wasn't where I was expecting to meet him and I'd gone in for a costume fitting and there he was and he just got me and he just stopped in the corridor and he looked at me, looked me up and down and went oh hello
加里，我第一次见到加里时，他走过拐角，是在Working Title的办公室，或者是在某个毫无灵感的地方，那不是我期望见到他的地方，我进去试装，他就站在那里，他只是抓住了我，他只是在走廊里停下来，他看着我，上下打量我，然后说，哦，你好。
I went oh hello hi I and just was just sort of just a mess in front of him yeah he was very very cool he was very cool and I thought oh fucking hell
我说，哦，你好，嗨，我……在他面前简直是一团糟。是的，他非常非常酷，他非常酷，我想，哦，该死。
I felt this horrible ill comfort of I've got to please this guy I've got to somehow impress him and make sure he thinks he literally felt like he was sized me out going this is really the guy I want to spend my time with
我感到这种可怕的不适，我必须取悦这个家伙，我必须以某种方式打动他，确保他认为他真的觉得他在打量我，心想，这真的是我想花时间在一起的家伙吗？
is Peter Gillum I'm not sure really you know there was a very kind of like it took a little while and then and then I I realized he he was the he was the one who was terrified
是彼得·吉勒姆吗？我真的不确定，你知道，有一种非常……这花了一点时间，然后，然后我意识到他……他才是那个感到恐惧的人。
he was terrified I think I can say this maybe his lawyers were right to me afterwards I don't know but he was frightened he really thought he wasn't capable of doing it he couldn't push this iconic Alec Guinness performance away he was worried that he hadn't found him
他感到恐惧，我想我可以这么说，也许他的律师后来对我说了，我不知道，但他很害怕。他真的认为他没有能力做到这一点，他无法推开这个标志性的亚历克·吉尼斯表演，他担心他没有找到他。
and you know it became the most amazing friendship out of that but you know yeah that that man was frightened and to have that vulnerability as an actor and to see that in someone as capable and extraordinary as him I was like, hooray, okay, we're all the same, really. We're all the fucking same. Yeah, but I mean, like, people feel that way about you.
而且，你知道，这从中产生了最了不起的友谊，但是，你知道，是的，那个人很害怕，作为演员拥有那种脆弱性，并在像他这样有能力和非凡的人身上看到这一点，我心想，万岁，好吧，我们真的都一样。我们都他妈的一样。是的，但我是说，人们对你也有这种感觉。
I think, you know, your body of work is, it's unmatched. Like, I mean, Star Trek, imitation game, I can name them because I've seen them, and I love them. And Dr. Strange, in August O'Sage County and the fucking smog. And, I mean, you're fucking smog and the Hobbit. I mean, that's crazy to me, to me. You know, and on and on and on. And recently, you know, the roses, I thought it was just like that, that was a total minefield.
我想，你知道，你的作品集是……它是无与伦比的。我是说，《星际迷航》、《模仿游戏》，我可以列举它们，因为我看过，而且我喜欢它们。《奇异博士》、《八月：奥色治郡》和该死的史矛革。而且，我是说，你是该死的史矛革和《霍比特人》。我是说，这对我来说太疯狂了。你知道，等等等等。最近，你知道，《玫瑰之家》，我认为这简直就像……那是一个完全的雷区。
You could have blown yourself up, you and Olivia, at any moment in that. It was truly impressive. So people feel that way about you too, I think, where. Oh, for sure. Or you just want to just, you know, if you get a job with Benedict coverbatch. Well, we'll know that I'm shitting it. Know that I don't know what I'm doing on a first day. Know that I doubt myself.
你和奥利维亚随时都可能在里面炸毁自己。这真的令人印象深刻。所以我认为人们对你也有这种感觉，在哪里。哦，当然。或者你只是想……你知道，如果你得到一份和本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇一起的工作。好吧，我们会知道我当时吓尿了。知道我在第一天不知道我在做什么。知道我怀疑自己。
You know, it's that thing, isn't it? And I don't know if you guys have it, but that first day on set where you go, you know, they're here's the crew, they were watching their actors, and directly you think, maybe they'll give me a second day, but these guys are just, they're going,
你知道，就是那回事，不是吗？我不知道你们是否有，但第一天在片场，你心想，你知道，他们在这里，这是剧组，他们正在看着他们的演员，直接你心想，也许他们会给我第二天，但这些家伙只是，他们正在……
it's Roman right away. And of course it isn't, because the focus pull is shitting it. The fucking clapable, you know, everyone is doing their job for the first time as a unit, putting stuff on film. So it's saying, you have to remember that and get over your own...
立刻就是罗马。当然不是，因为跟焦员吓尿了。该死的场记板，你知道，每个人都在第一次作为一个整体做他们的工作，把东西拍成电影。所以它是说，你必须记住这一点，并克服你自己的……
We all have to figure out how to watch. wash ourselves, right, Sean? That's right. We're all human. But I do, I do want to, just having done a show there in London. In the back, too. Do you do the same for the back? Show me how you do.
我们都必须弄清楚如何洗澡，对吧，肖恩？没错。我们都是人类。但我确实，我确实想，刚刚在伦敦做了一场演出。在后面也是。你对后面也做同样的事吗？给我看你是怎么做的。
Show me how you do, how do you wash your own smaller your back? Let me just see that. Do you need an extender for the lufa? Because we've got one. Scotty? Oh, wow. It's a selfie stick. How old are you?
给我看你是怎么做的，你怎么洗你自己的后背？让我看看。你需要一个丝瓜络的延长杆吗？因为我们有一个。斯科蒂？哦，哇。这是自拍杆。你多大了？
You're so nimble. Flex. No, but in theater, in London, they have this. and the barbican they have this thing called cherish notes and i've never heard of this until i went over there and i'm like and i had to ask people in the cast i'm like what's cherish cherish notes well we meet every single day every day before the show on stage just check in with each other i'm like can't we do that just backstage in the hall or where the dressing rooms are yeah or just in the e that's what i said can we just do an email or like a fax or something
你真灵活。炫耀。不，但在伦敦的剧院，他们有这个。在巴比肯，他们有这个叫“珍惜笔记”的东西，我从来没听说过，直到我去了那里，我心想，我不得不问剧组的人，我心想，什么是珍惜笔记？好吧，我们每天，每天在演出前在舞台上见面，只是互相检查一下。我心想，我们不能就在后台大厅或者更衣室所在的地方做吗？是的，或者就在……那就是我说的，我们不能只发个邮件或传真什么的吗？
And, no, you have to go on stage. And every day we would go on stage, and the stage manager would be like, great, I don't have anything, does anybody have anything to? Like, no, why are we standing here? I like that. I like that. It keeps everybody accountable and reminds you of where you are.
而且，不，你必须上台。每天我们都会上台，舞台经理会说，太棒了，我没什么事，有人有什么要……吗？就像，不，我们为什么要站在这里？我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。它让每个人都负责，并提醒你你在哪里。
Yes, I know, but, okay. What do you think about that, Benedict? I think it's quite lovely. I think it's quite nice. I think it's quite nice. As long as you're not spending too much time doing that. And as long as there's a moderator, I think what the dangerous thing is,
是的，我知道，但是，好吧。你对此怎么看，本尼迪克特？我觉得这很可爱。我觉得这很好。我觉得这很好。只要你没有花太多时间做那个。而且只要有一个主持人，我认为危险的事情是，
especially in theatre long run, like there's going to be those moments where something's going a bit strange in a scene or someone's, you know, and then the lines of communication can get very, very fuzzy unless you go through the appropriate channels, which is, you know, the assistant director
特别是在戏剧长期演出中，就像会有那些时刻，场景中有些事情变得有点奇怪，或者有人，你知道，然后沟通渠道可能会变得非常非常模糊，除非你通过适当的渠道，也就是，你知道，助理导演
or the director and say, I'm having a bit of a problem with the scene, I'm not sure it's quite awake, whatever it is. If you go in there in the Cherish scenario and go to another actor, you know that bit where you're doing that bit. That means I can't do my bit the way I want to do it,
或者导演，说，我在场景中遇到了一点问题，我不确定它是否完全清醒，无论是什么。如果你在“珍惜”场景中进去，去找另一个演员，你知道你做那个部分的那个部分吗？这意味着我不能按照我想做的方式做我的部分，
but that to me is like, oh, here we go but that's not what cherishing is cherishing sounds much nicer than that but I guess if it becomes it cherishing is just a positive feedback loop isn't it that's what that is and just looking after each other
但那对我来说就像，哦，开始了，但那不是珍惜的意义。珍惜听起来比那好得多，但我猜如果它变成了……珍惜只是一个积极的反馈循环，不是吗？这就是那个，只是互相照顾。
but it was nice to see everybody but if somebody brings up something is there enough time? I mean everybody in your castes already they feel like fucking this guy just barely put up with it no I loved everybody there is there enough time to iron out whatever problem somebody might bring
但看到每个人都很好，但如果有人提出什么事情，有足够的时间吗？我是说，你剧组里的每个人都已经，他们觉得该死，这家伙只是勉强忍受它。不，我爱那里的每个人。有足够的时间来解决某人可能带来的任何问题吗？
well that's what that's what it was that's what it was I wasn't used to it here like in the States where you kind of it kind of interrupts what you've created for yourself your rhythm and your routine
好吧，那就是……那就是它。我在这里不习惯，像在美国，你有点……它有点打断了你为你自己创造的节奏和常规。
in the States and so when I was like oh I have to stop that go up five flights of stairs or down five flights of stairs oh my God I know it's terrible these monsters this gets worse
在美国，所以当我心想，哦，我必须停止那个，走上五层楼梯或走下五层楼梯，天哪，我知道这很糟糕，这些怪物，这变得更糟。
five flights of stairs I mean and you can barely we know that you can't swim because you can barely catch your breath And then at the top of the stairs, you had to say something nice about it. Yeah, and I went down the stairs like this. It's just a tub of water and just get in it.
五层楼梯，我是说，你几乎……我们知道你不会游泳，因为你几乎喘不过气来。然后在楼梯顶端，你必须说一些关于它的好话。是的，我像这样走下楼梯。这只是一个水桶，进去就行了。
Let me watch you. Just dip in. Is it still hot? Just dip in it. Let me see. I want to talk about, well, Shawnee, do you want to get it into it? Sean, would you want to talk more about Dr. Strange or Star Trek because I'd love to get it in 1917 when you're done?
让我看着你。进去泡一下。它还热吗？进去泡一下。让我看看。我想谈谈，好吧，肖尼，你想进去吗？肖恩，你想多谈谈《奇异博士》或《星际迷航》吗，因为我很想在你做完后谈谈《1917》？
Yeah, no. I mean, look. Are you big into fantasy, Sean? Is that your fantasy? Yeah, I'm a huge sci-fi nerd and fantasy. Is he into fantasy? Is he into fantasy?
是的，不。我是说，看。你很喜欢奇幻吗，肖恩？那是你的奇幻吗？是的，我是个超级科幻迷和奇幻迷。他喜欢奇幻吗？他喜欢奇幻吗？
You should see what he's wearing for bottoms right now. He's a full lizard suit from the waist on. Yeah. So Sean loves... I love Star Trek and the movies. You love Marvel. You love Marvel. Yeah, I like Marvel.
你应该看看他现在的裤子穿的是什么。他从腰部以下是一套完整的蜥蜴装。是的。所以肖恩喜欢……我喜欢《星际迷航》和电影。你喜欢漫威。你喜欢漫威。是的，我喜欢漫威。
Scotty loves Marvel. I like Marvel a lot. but I love Star Trek movies. I wasn't a huge fan of the television series like Scott. This guy's massive Star Trek fan. But seeing you on screen
斯科蒂喜欢漫威。我非常喜欢漫威。但我喜欢《星际迷航》电影。我不是电视连续剧的超级粉丝，像斯科特。这家伙是《星际迷航》的铁杆粉丝。但看到你在屏幕上
as that character, that iconic character, and I don't know, you have this thing about you where you don't, you're so fucking commanding. Yeah, you're magnetic. Like, right, you don't have to do a lot
作为那个角色，那个标志性的角色，我不知道，你身上有这种东西，你不会，你太他妈的令人敬畏了。是的，你很有磁性。就像，对吧，你不需要做很多
and you're just, you're electric right through the fucking screen. dressing. Do you want Sean, do you want Scottie to come ask a question? By the way, if Scotty comes on camera and he's covered in French as mustard up and around. Wait, let me see if he's got a question. With spock ears.
你只是，你穿过该死的屏幕是带电的。着装。你想让肖恩，你想让斯科蒂来问个问题吗？顺便说一句，如果斯科蒂出现在镜头前，他身上沾满了法式芥末酱。等等，让我看看他有没有问题。戴着史波克耳朵。
But also my massive, massive Lord of the Rings Hobbit fan, like huge. I've seen him a million times as movies and to see, right when you popped on today as a guest, I'm like, oh my God, that's so, it's such an icon, another iconic character that smog, the drag. that your voice is synonymous with this legendary thing.
而且也是我的超级、超级《指环王》、《霍比特人》粉丝，就像超级粉丝。我看了他一百万次电影，看到，当你今天作为嘉宾出现时，我心想，天哪，那太……那是一个偶像，另一个标志性角色，史矛革，那条龙。你的声音与这个传奇事物是同义词。
And, Sean, I will say this, Benedict, before you, I've asked people who've done these kinds of things before. You've done a bunch of these different films, you know, sort of franchises, if you will, but they came out of very well-established, you know, sort of ideas that have a very well-established fan base. And there's a sense of, do you ever feel a sense of responsibility
而且，肖恩，我会说这个，本尼迪克特，在你之前，我问过以前做过这些事情的人。你做过很多这些不同的电影，你知道，特许经营，如果你愿意的话，但它们来自非常成熟的，你知道，某种想法，有一个非常成熟的粉丝群。有一种感觉，你有没有感到一种责任感
to those legions of fans who existed before you kind of stepped into these roles? Yeah, huge. very big and then you have to forget about them you have to you have to make a commitment to something that can't please everyone so that's immediately if you pay the aggregate game you're dead in the water to anything original or alive or daring or that asks questions or is worth actually seeing the 78th or whatever I was version of Sherlock Holmes you have to just go
对那些在你踏入这些角色之前就存在的粉丝军团？是的，巨大。非常大，然后你必须忘记他们。你必须，你必须对某些不能取悦所有人的事情做出承诺。所以如果这是你玩的总和游戏，你对任何原创的、活着的、大胆的、提出问题的或值得一看的东西来说就死定了，或者无论我是第78个版本的夏洛克·福尔摩斯，你必须只是去
no it's going to be all right and that that it's it's not arrogance it's it's just you can't have that much head traffic you just have to focus on doing the job and so yeah it's a take on on something yeah i forgot i forgot about sherlock too which is fantastic i loved sherlock you were so great in sherlock i mean the list goes on and on this guy i mean you even 35 yet and the resume is stunning you know it's anyway with with we're already over time i've got one last question though because it's something to bring you back down to earth because you're so goddamn good at at what you're do what is the what is the one thing you'd love to be half as good at as you are as an actor is there
不，这会没事的，那……那不是傲慢，那……那只是你不能有那么多的头部流量，你只需要专注于做好工作。所以是的，这是对某事的诠释。是的，我忘了，我也忘了夏洛克，这太棒了。我喜欢夏洛克，你在夏洛克里太棒了。我是说，名单还在继续，这家伙，我是说，你甚至还没35岁，简历就令人惊叹。你知道，无论如何，我们已经超时了，但我有一个最后一个问题，因为这是为了让你回到地球，因为你太他妈的擅长你所做的事情了。你最想在什么事情上达到你作为演员一半的水平？有没有
something surfing surfing oh wow really or speaking any foreign language so you try but you're not great uh exactly that i'm i'm i started in my 40s and i'm near the end of my 40s and i'm still feeling like i'm starting but it and i had a shot operation last year so i haven't done it at all for about actually know this year for about six months but i love it i love it's where did you start it Weirdly enough, in New Zealand, when we were doing Power of the Dog, we got shut down because of lockdown and we had the decision to make to stay, which by then, because I had two octogenarian parents, one of whom is a severe asthmatic staying with us, as it would happen,
冲浪冲浪，哦哇，真的吗，或者说任何外语，所以你尝试了但做得不是很好，呃，完全正确，我是在40多岁时开始的，现在快到40岁末了，感觉自己还是刚入门，而且我去年做了肩部手术，所以实际上今年有六个月完全没做，但我热爱它，我热爱它，你是在哪里开始的？说来奇怪，在新西兰，我们在拍《犬之力》时，因为封锁被叫停了，我们必须决定是否留下来，当时因为我有两位八十多岁的父母，其中一位患有严重哮喘，碰巧和我们住在一起，
my mum and dad and our three very young children at that point, Sophie and a nanny, and we just thought, okay, we're going to stay. And it was a bit scary to begin with, but utterly magical and extraordinary, one of the best places on earth to be, as it turned out. And there was a little left-hand break in Tiawunga in Hawks Bay. Big shout out to Tiawungans. Anyway, the point is it was where I learned. And I'm goofy, actually, so left break's not as good as a right.
我的父母，还有我们当时三个非常年幼的孩子，苏菲和保姆，我们想，好吧，我们要留下来。起初有点害怕，但后来发现这里简直神奇又非凡，是地球上最好的地方之一。在霍克斯湾的蒂奥温加有一个小小的左手浪点。向蒂奥温加人致敬。总之，重点是我就是在那里学会的。而且我是“古菲”站姿（右脚在前），所以左手浪不如右手浪好。
But I quite like, no, that's wrong. It must have been a right break. Yeah, because I'm right foot forward. So you're supposed to be facing the wave around the facing the shore. So I learned really on the wrong wave, but loved it. Every now and again, you get a left. And I just, I really. fell in love with it i fell in love with the view of the coastline um i fell in love with that connection
但我挺喜欢，不，那不对。那一定是个右手浪。是的，因为我是右脚在前。所以你应该面向海浪，面向岸边。所以我其实是在错误的浪上学的，但我很喜欢。偶尔你会遇到一个左手浪。我真的爱上了它，我爱上了海岸线的风景，嗯，我爱上了那种与海洋的连接，
to the ocean that sense of how present you are and the community as well this extraordinary group of people where all is kind of forgiven as long as you don't take their wave and you know the drug dealer would be there and the head of the local police force would be there you know it's just all of human life was around you right and i i can't i can't explain to anyone has itself what that feeling is of nature giving you a ride from somewhere out in the ocean towards the shoreline it's just magic when it works and when you get out of the ocean how do you clean yourself i'm kidding what happened what happened to your shoulder by the way you got shoulder surgery i i was so boring it's so so so 49 um yeah i'm 50 to say but it was 49 when it
那种身临其境的感觉，还有社区，这群非凡的人，只要你不抢他们的浪，一切都可以原谅，你知道毒贩会在那里，当地警察局长也会在那里，你知道，你周围全是形形色色的人，我无法向任何人解释大自然把你从海洋深处带向岸边是什么感觉，当它奏效时简直太神奇了，当你从海里出来时，你怎么清理自己？开个玩笑，顺便问一下你的肩膀怎么了？你做了肩部手术？我太无聊了，太49岁了，嗯，是的，我50岁了，但发生时是49岁，
happened i bet well it's a long time of ill-use and done a lot of surfing in very bad conditions and over doing it. I'm probably lifting stuff in the wrong way over the years. Not the particular, but I basically had a torn rotator cuff and then also a frozen shoulder on top of it, which only did the repair to the rotator, which was a complete tear.
我敢打赌，这是长期使用不当造成的，在很糟糕的条件下冲浪太多，过度劳累。我可能多年来搬东西的方式也不对。不是特定的原因，但我基本上是肩袖撕裂，上面还有冻结肩，我只做了肩袖修复手术，那是完全撕裂。
And I'd lived with chronic pain for about a year and a half not really realising that you didn't have to. And I kept on doing physio and being told, no, it'll heal, just give it time. I'm a patient guy, and I'm doing everything you're telling me to do, and I'm still having sleepless nights, getting out
我带着慢性疼痛生活了一年半，没意识到其实不必这样。我一直做物理治疗，被告知，不，它会愈合的，给它点时间。我是一个有耐心的人，我照着你们说的做，但我还是彻夜难眠，
like three, four times in the night because I'd rolled over onto it and it's suddenly just... Right, but it's better now? It's, yeah, it's great. It's great. Oh, great. I love that. Oh, look at that. Well, before we let you go, we need to know about the thing with feathers
晚上起来三四次，因为我翻身压到了它，突然就……好吧，但现在好多了？是的，好多了。太棒了。哦，太好了。我喜欢这个。哦，看那个。好吧，在你走之前，我们需要了解一下《悲伤是长羽毛的东西》这个项目，
because this is this new project, you guys. If I hadn't said anything about that film, I was so sorry. It's not how to clean yourself. It's very much not the thing with feathers. I mean, I suppose you could use that to clean yourself. It's a prequel to how do you clean yourself. Yeah, so this, this, I... It's called a duster.
因为这是你们的新项目，伙计们。如果我没提那部电影，我会很抱歉。这不是“如何清理自己”。它绝对不是“长羽毛的东西”。我是说，你或许可以用那个来清理自己。这是“如何清理自己”的前传。是的，所以这个，我……它叫除尘掸。
I've only seen the trailer, which is, is, looks magical to say the least. What is it called? The thing with feathers. Okay. It's, it's, I'm not going to ask you to describe because I think that's, that's always frustrating. But it seems like there's, there's, there's, you're dealing with loss, but you're dealing with it in a very, uh, magical, fantastical way. and it looks like the filmmaking is exquisite and your performance looks mind-blowing again was it something that you love doing?
我只看了预告片，至少可以说看起来很神奇。它叫什么？《悲伤是长羽毛的东西》。好的。我不会让你描述它，因为我觉得那总是很令人沮丧。但看起来你是在处理失去，但你以一种非常神奇、奇幻的方式处理它。而且电影制作看起来非常精致，你的表演看起来再次令人震撼，这是你喜欢做的事情吗？
Very much and it's something that I'm very proud of. I produced it as well so it's one of those projects that wouldn't really have got off the ground well I would have probably got off the ground but it took a lot of efforts and it was 10 years in the making we only came on board in the last sort of of year and a bit of it.
非常喜欢，而且我为此感到非常自豪。我也参与了制作，所以这是一个如果没有努力可能就不会启动的项目，好吧，我可能还是会启动它，但它花费了大量精力，筹备了10年，我们只在最后一年多一点的时候才加入。
We being the production company, Sunny March, Adam Acklin, Leah Clark and myself. And it was an approach for me to act as this dad, this man who, because you were so kind in telling me it could be a real bore to describe it. I'm going to describe it very, very briefly. But it's a man who suffers a very sudden bereavement and he loses his wife and has to bring up his two children
我们指的是制作公司Sunny March，亚当·阿克林，莉亚·克拉克和我自己。对我来说，这是一个扮演这位父亲的方法，这个男人，因为你很客气地告诉我描述它可能很无聊。我会非常非常简短地描述它。这是一个遭受突如其来的丧亲之痛的男人，他失去了妻子，不得不作为鳏夫抚养他的两个孩子，
as a widow, and it's about their first year as a family. And it's based on an amazing, amazing novella called Grief is the Thing with Feathers. Oh wow. Which is a misquote of the famous Emily Dickinson line, Love is the Thing with Feathers. By Max Porter,
这是他们作为家庭的第一年。它基于一本非常非常棒的中篇小说，叫《悲伤是长羽毛的东西》。哦哇。这是对艾米莉·狄金森名句“希望是长羽毛的东西”的误引。作者是马克斯·波特，
who is just a titan of a heroic human being in actual physical stature and in talent. He's a wonderfully kind, brilliant mind and he's created a space where male grief is examined in the most unimaginably
他无论在实际体格还是才华上都是一位英雄般的巨人。他是一位非常善良、才华横溢的思想家，他创造了一个空间，以最不可思议、最疯狂、最富有想象力的方式审视男性的悲伤。
crazy and imaginative way. It's about dealing with it as an acceptance as something you live with and it comes alive in the form of the dad's work which from the book
它是关于接受它作为你生活的一部分，它以父亲作品的形式活了过来，从书中，
maybe the film but certainly the book more or less is hinted at as being a memory of the boys of what that time was like and you kind of learn that as the story unfolds
也许是电影，但肯定是书中，或多或少暗示这是孩子们对那段时光的记忆，随着故事的展开，你会逐渐了解到这一点，
but it's a crow it's a crow that comes fully to life as this horrific entity that's both Mary Poppins to the children and Amenuensis a hero
但它是一只乌鸦，这只乌鸦完全活了过来，成为了一个可怕的实体，对孩子们来说，它既是玛丽·波平斯，又是速记员，一个英雄，
an absolute nightmare a ferocious noise in the head a tormentor and an ally against despair and it's a huge homage to the literature it was born out of the poetry of Ted Hughes in our version he was an academic at the book in our version he's an illustrator and his illustration comes to life basically
一个绝对的噩梦，脑海中狂暴的噪音，一个折磨者，也是对抗绝望的盟友，这是对它所诞生的文学作品的巨大致敬，它源于泰德·休斯的诗歌，在我们的版本中，他是书中的学者，在我们的版本中，他是插画家，他的插画基本上活了过来，
and lives torments and is accepted by this family grieving the loss of their mother and wife wow wow wow I can't wait to check it that's a punchy hour and 40 minutes and it's yeah i don't know i just what i was taken with with the trailer is you know you all can can see there's it seems to be done in such a sophisticated cinematic tasteful way like you know that you that can go wrong real quick if you go oh so there's going to be a crow that he's got to talk to that's like how does that look and how is it framed what's like you know it's
并生活、折磨，并被这个哀悼母亲和妻子离世的家庭所接受。哇哇哇，我迫不及待想看了，那是一个紧凑的一小时四十分钟，是的，我不知道，我只是，预告片吸引我的是，你们都能看到，它似乎是以一种如此精致、电影化、有品位的方式完成的，你知道，如果你说“哦，会有一只乌鸦他必须和它说话”，那可能会很快出错，那看起来会怎样，它是如何构图的，你知道，它
just looks so tasteful and and special. So, congratulations. Well, thank you. I mean, that's mainly down to Dylan Southern, who adapted the book and directed it. He's a pop documentarian by trade, as in that's what he's done up until this point.
看起来如此有品位且特别。所以，恭喜。谢谢。我的意思是，这主要归功于迪伦·萨瑟恩，他改编了这本书并执导了它。他职业上是一位流行纪录片导演，也就是说，这是他到目前为止所做的事情。
This is first fictional narrative drama. Good for you for getting behind him. Well, yeah, I mean, that's one of the things we do at Sunday, much. We want to promote and platform voices that are coming out of the stocks, who are the first, and very often female-led talent, but also, in this case, someone who hasn't originated their work in this medium,
这是他第一部虚构叙事剧情片。很高兴你支持他。嗯，是的，我的意思是，这是我们在Sunny March做的事情之一。我们想推广和提供平台给那些初出茅庐的声音，他们是第一次，而且通常是女性主导的人才，但在这种情况下，是一个没有在这种媒介中创作过作品的人，
and he's spectacular. He's a real sinuous. He's a real cultural nurse. So the references are thick and fast. There's Kubrick, there's Spielberg, there's Hitchcock. There's all sorts of, but of Jane Campion in there weirdly. But it is just, it's a rich tapestry of imagination and minds coming undone reflected through a cinematic idea of how that would happen in the culture of these people.
他很壮观。他是一个真正的天才。他是一个真正的文化护士。所以参考资料非常丰富且快速。有库布里克，有斯皮尔伯格，有希区柯克。有各种各样的，奇怪的是还有简·坎皮恩的影子。但这只是一个想象力和思想崩溃的丰富挂毯，通过电影化的理念反映了这些人在他们的文化中会如何发生。
So it's the father's imagination and that North London 40-something maleness which I know very well that's set in South Island but big deal not much difference and it's just it's it's it was it was a crazy ride to go on very short shoots after 10 years of of creating it and getting it made so I'm really proud of it before we let you go I have to ask you about something that I think that you have been
所以这是父亲的想象力和那种我非常熟悉的北伦敦40多岁的男性气质，虽然背景设定在南岛，但没什么大不了的，差别不大，这真是一次疯狂的旅程，在创造和制作了10年之后，拍摄时间却很短，所以我真的很自豪。在你走之前，我必须问你一件事，我认为你已经
attached to to either be in or to produce or to do something with for a long time and it's one of my favorite books of all time it's an absolute mindblower for those who haven't written which is you know what I'm about to say rogue mail rogue mail oh dude it's a winner isn't that it's so cool it is such a game changer of a novel
参与其中很久了，要么是出演，要么是制作，或者做点什么，这是我最喜欢的书之一，对那些没读过的人来说绝对是震撼心灵的，你知道我要说什么，《浪人》，《浪人》，哦伙计，这是一个赢家，不是吗？太酷了，这是一部改变游戏规则的小说，
rogue mail written in 1939 yeah it's it's the original fugitive novel it's the original and you know a huge inspiration for Ian Fleming for Bond and yeah and it's and it's so prescient to what's going on in our times, not to allude to that too much. It's so pressing, exactly, and it really is.
《浪人》写于1939年，是的，它是最初的逃亡小说，它是原创的，你知道，它是伊恩·弗莱明创作邦德的巨大灵感来源，是的，它对我们这个时代正在发生的事情非常有预见性，不想过多暗示这一点。它太紧迫了，确实如此，真的。
You know, when we first sat down trying to talk about this, is this a bit of a game, it's not about AI, I know, but is this a bit of a kind of guy's film, and then the longer we were exploring the themes of it and the motivation behind the guy's actions and the outcome and how he's turned on by his own side as well as obviously the side he's tried to take down, it's fascinating how it plays into a political spectrum
你知道，当我们第一次坐下来试图谈论这个时，这有点像个游戏，我知道这不是关于人工智能，但这是否有点像那种男人的电影，然后我们越深入探讨它的主题，以及这个男人行为背后的动机和结果，以及他如何被自己的一方以及他试图打倒的一方背叛，它如何影响政治光谱，这真是太迷人了，
of what's going on in the world. now i don't want to say too much about it because people should read the book and yeah we will make it you will make it huh definitely oh yeah we don't we don't got a filming date yet but it's it's something we're trying to slate for next year although there are other huge commitments involving cloaks floating about so yeah i'll be the first guy to watch it i'll be the first one there it's just what that is i can't wait uh me too yeah i know it's nice to get going on that that's good um well we uh we owe you uh 12 minutes now in back into your life uh we just I think I owe you a lot more because I was very late on, so you, I mean, nothing.
关于世界上正在发生的事情。现在我不想说太多，因为人们应该去读这本书，是的，我们会把它拍出来，你会拍出来，是吗？绝对的，哦是的，我们还没有拍摄日期，但这是我们试图为明年安排的项目，尽管还有其他涉及斗篷的巨大承诺，所以是的，我会是第一个看它的人，我会是第一个到场的人，这太棒了，我迫不及待了，我也是，是的，我知道开始做那个很好，那很好，嗯，我们欠你12分钟回到你的生活中，我们只是，我想我欠你更多，因为我迟到了，所以你，我的意思是，没什么。
No, no, no, I'm very glad to be. Such a pleasure, honor to have you on the show, Benedict. Thank you. Likewise, guys. Really cool to meet you. I'm really good to meet you all too. Thank you. I hope to bump into you again soon one day.
不，不，不，我很高兴。非常荣幸，本尼迪克特，能请你上节目。谢谢。同样，伙计们。很高兴见到你们。我也很高兴见到你们所有人。谢谢。希望有一天能再见到你。
Continued success, Benedict. You too, you too. Well, sorry, I've got to say, Will, before we sign off, you were phenomenal in this thing on. Oh, is it fucking great. I asked Bradley, because I've missed to give me a link because searchlight wouldn't. Oh, it's not really ready for a link yet. And I went, fucking Bradley, I missed a screening of it in London.
祝你继续成功，本尼迪克特。你也是，你也是。好吧，抱歉，我必须说，威尔，在我们结束之前，你在那个东西里表现得非常出色。哦，太棒了。我问了布拉德利，因为我错过了，让他给我一个链接，因为探照灯公司不给。哦，还没准备好给链接。我说，该死的布拉德利，我错过了它在伦敦的放映。
I can see it. You are so good. It's so tender and real. And that camera is so... I wanted to ask you about how you deal with... It's so close to you all the time when you're up at that mic. Like, was he shooting on a long lens at any point? Or was it really on stage with you getting in your eye line?
我能看出来。你太棒了。它如此温柔和真实。那台摄像机如此……我想问你你是如何处理……当你站在麦克风前时，它一直离你那么近。比如，他在任何时候都是用长焦镜头拍摄的吗？还是真的在舞台上和你在一起，进入你的视线？
I mean, it was... And yet you're utterly in it all the time. And it's so moving. It was all in a 40. The whole thing was shot... Everything was shot under 40, the entire film. Yeah. On one single lens.
我的意思是，它是……然而你一直完全沉浸在其中。这太感人了。它全是在40毫米镜头下拍摄的。整件事都是拍摄的……整部电影都是在40毫米下拍摄的。是的。用同一个镜头。
And he was, yeah, Bradley was right there. you know right up next to me it was very intense but thank you very much it's so impressive yeah yeah it's pretty work it's brilliant work anyway i just wanted to throw that in it's a really good um all right will you enjoy the rest of your night um and um and thank you again for doing this pal by benedette cumberbatch thank you jason thank you will thank you shorn see you bad take care bye bye bye bye there he goes benedict cumberbatch i didn't i didn't get to so much that went by Oh, my God, there's...
而且他，是的，布拉德利就在那里。你知道就在我旁边，非常紧张，但非常感谢，这太令人印象深刻了，是的，是的，这是很棒的工作，这是辉煌的工作，总之，我只是想提一下，这真的很好，嗯，好吧，威尔，享受你剩下的夜晚，嗯，再次感谢你做这件事，伙计，再见本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇，谢谢杰森，谢谢威尔，谢谢肖恩，再见，保重，再见，再见，再见，他走了，本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇，我没能，太多事情过去了，哦，天哪，有……
How could you? He's got a million credits. I know, right? Yeah, that was really cool. I mean, are you guys a Lord of the Rings Hobbit fan? No? I've not seen those. I enjoyed it.
你怎么能这样？他有上百万部作品。我知道，对吧？是的，那真的很酷。我的意思是，你们是《指环王》或《霍比特人》的粉丝吗？不？我没看过那些。我很喜欢。
Yeah, I loved those movies. So, yeah. He was the voice. There were some motion capture questions I have here, but I didn't get to them. Yeah, but you could tell... Because he was just a voice of a dragon, I hear from your question, yeah? That is correct. But also, you can tell...
是的，我喜欢那些电影。所以，是的。他是那个声音。我这里有一些关于动作捕捉的问题，但我没来得及问。是的，但你可以看出来……因为他只是龙的声音，我从你的问题中听到的，对吧？那是正确的。但你也可以看出来……
from talking to him he's this sounds really corny to say but you could tell he's such a massive team player you can say you can tell he's not you know he's a very giving person he's a very loving down to earth you can smell his team spirit yeah yeah nice smells like teen teen spirit oh i see yeah um no he's uh he's uh he's pretty it's pretty cool how he's uh dances between the comedy the drama the big the big the big big Marvel stuff and also like things like this thing coming out. I know, like intense, like little sort of really cool niche films and then these massive box office hits. Are you with them?
从和他交谈中，他，说这话听起来很老套，但你可以看出他是一个非常出色的团队合作者，你可以看出他不是，你知道，他是一个非常慷慨的人，他是一个非常有爱心、脚踏实地的人，你可以闻到他的团队精神，是的，是的，闻起来像青少年精神，哦，我明白了，是的，嗯，不，他，他，他很酷，他如何在喜剧、戏剧、大型漫威作品以及像这个即将推出的东西之间游刃有余。我知道，就像紧张的、小型的、非常酷的利基电影，然后是这些巨大的票房热门。你和他们在一起吗？
Are you with them? They're now and you can just jump in with them. The listener, Will's building on the clean yourself. Jump in there with them and then you guys together. You can clean each other. More easily reach the back. You just do that. Start there.
你和他们在一起吗？他们现在就在那里，你可以直接加入他们。听众，威尔正在建立“清理自己”。加入他们，然后你们一起。你们可以互相清理。更容易够到背部。你就那样做。从那里开始。
Is it a button or a zipper I asked before? Oh, my God. But, Hey, Will, was I with you on a plane when we ran into Benedict Cumberbatch? Oh, really? Was I with you on a plane or was somebody else? Anyway, I ran into him on a plane once
我之前问过是按钮还是拉链？哦，天哪。但是，嘿，威尔，我和你在飞机上遇到本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇时，我是在你身边吗？哦，真的吗？我是在飞机上和你在一起，还是别人？总之，我曾在飞机上遇到过他，
and he was so fucking funny. I didn't run into him a plane, I don't think, but I ran into him once. I didn't remember. So I didn't say how to him, he was at the Greenwich and he was trying to repack a suitcase in the lobby. Oh, no. And I was like, you know what I'm going to do?
他太搞笑了。我不认为我是在飞机上遇到他的，但我确实遇到过他一次。我不记得了。所以我没跟他打招呼，他在格林威治，他正试图在大堂里重新打包行李箱。哦，不。我就想，你知道我要做什么吗？
I'm going to leave him alone. You know, that's a way. I hate looking inside somebody's suitcase. You ever notice that? Why? I feel like there's stuff in there I don't need to see, don't want to see, especially, not the suitcase on the way to the destination.
我要让他一个人待着。你知道，那是一种方式。我讨厌看别人的行李箱里面。你注意到了吗？为什么？我觉得里面有我不需要看、不想看的东西，尤其是，不是去目的地的行李箱。
It's the one coming back where all the dirty underwear is up on top and it's folded and it's all just like, you just know if you got your face in there, You're so crazy. You're so crazy about just regular life. You're so fucking insane. By the one big luxury, the thing, the one big luxury that I love, that I really love treating myself to, is doing hotel laundry.
是回来的时候，所有的脏内衣都在上面，折叠着，一切都像，你只要知道如果你把脸凑过去，你太疯狂了。你对日常生活太疯狂了。你真是太疯狂了。我喜欢的一大奢侈，我真的很喜欢犒劳自己的一件事，就是做酒店洗衣。
Oh, you just throw it, you give it, and you put it in the bag, and let them take it. People are like, oh, I'm not going to do a hotel laundry. You're going to be $4 for my socks. I'm like, yeah, you know what? I'm going to treat myself. So you do that laundry before you leave the hotel so that when you get home and you unpack, it's already done? Yeah, depending.
哦，你只是扔掉它，你给它，你把它放进袋子里，让他们拿走。人们会说，哦，我才不会做酒店洗衣。你要为我的袜子付4美元。我说，是的，你知道吗？我要犒劳自己。所以你在离开酒店之前做那次洗衣，这样当你回家拆包时，它已经洗好了？是的，取决于情况。
I mean, the last few, there might be a few items, but I'm not going to, like, just deprive myself, you know what I mean? So you don't go home with all your dirty laundry like the rest of us, plebs, and throw it in the machine? I'll often do, the bulk of my stuff will be clean, yeah. Yeah. I'm not jackassing a bunch of dirty clothes across the globe. Why would you?
我的意思是，最后几次，可能有一些物品，但我不会，就像，剥夺自己，你知道我的意思吗？所以你不会像我们这些平民一样带着所有的脏衣服回家，然后扔进洗衣机？我通常会做，我的大部分东西都会是干净的，是的。是的。我不会把一堆脏衣服带到全球各地。你为什么要那样做？
Yeah, when you got all that money to burn, right? Yeah. Like an extra 12 bucks. Oh, is it? For a T-shirt? Nice. But listen, all those. Here he comes.
是的，当你有很多钱可以烧的时候，对吧？是的。就像多花12块钱？哦，是吗？买一件T恤？不错。但听着，所有那些。他来了。
Did I meet Benedict Cumberbatch on an aeroplane, like a jet plane, or was it a biplane? I'm going to be a biplane, but we'll allow it, bye. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly. Handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是在飞机上，像喷气式飞机，还是双翼飞机上遇到本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的？我要说是双翼飞机，但我们会允许的，再见。Smartless。Smartless。Smartless是100%有机的，由罗伯·阿姆贾夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作。Smartless。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。